HEARING.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH --
ITEMS SIX FOUR FOUR ZERO
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S SIX
SIX ONE ZERO CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND SIX NINE EIGHT ZERO
CALIFORNIA'S TO NAY COMMISSION
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS MAYOR VISION
HIGHER EDUCATION PROPOSALS.
LET'S SEE WE NEED HERE'S SO --
FINANCE CAN SET UP THERE IF WE
HAVE AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH LA --
CAN BE OVER HERE -- AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE CHAIRS SO.
PHYLLIS LET'S SEE ELLIS.
SO I CAN KEEP EVERYBODY STRAIGHT
OKAY EVERYBODY HAS A MIKE NOW.
LET'S -- I HAVE YOU ALL
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD -- TRIED AT THE WHAT THE
TEST WE'RE GONNA START AT THE
TABLE TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT
AND THAT'S USER.
MY NAME IS RYAN STORM I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE.
SAVOR TANNIN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING DAVID A RUN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION.
BRIAN OKAY LET'S GO OVER HERE.
JAX WELL THE FORMER FINANCE.
SEE YOU SIR GEN MERRY OUR
FINANCE.
IN BOSTON HOUSE IN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
INTERESTING HASN'T GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK.
THE THINKING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
JASON CONCENTRA SLUDGE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
OKAY WAS TO START.
THIS IS A HIGHER EDUCATION.
ANY SO TAKE ORDERS WILL BEGIN
WITH THE FINANCIALLY PROPOSALS
AND SOON A COMMISSION.
SO THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
TOTAL FINANCIAL AID EXPENDITURES
OF JUST OVER TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION. TWO TIMES DURING THE
YEAR AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT
THE MAY REVISION WE UPDATE THE
ESTIMATES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
DETERMINING THE TOTAL COST OF
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS.
SO THE AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
THERE ARE NUMBER OF ADJUSTMENTS
THOSE PROGRAMS WERE HAPPY TO GO
INTO DEPTH ON ANY OF THEM. TO
KIND OF SPEAK UP A HIGH LEVEL
THE MOST IMPORTANT POLICY
PROPOSALS ARE THE PROPOSAL OF
EIGHTY NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
COMMISSION TO ADMINISTER AND
CREATE A NEW LOAN FORGIVENESS.
PROGRAM FOR TEACHERS WHO MEETS
SPECIFIED CRITERIA AND YOU TEACH
OF CERTAIN SCHOOLS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING THAT
THE FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS BE ADMINISTERED BY THIS
YOU NEED COMMISSION.
AND FURTHER THE FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND THAT WAS
PROPOSED FOR THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RICH AND RESEARCH
TO ADMINISTER.
A STUDENT LOAN AWARENESS
INITIATIVE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
TRANSFERRED TO THE US YOU NEED
COMMISSION.
IN ADDITION WE'RE PROPOSING
THROUGH TRAILER BILL TO MOVE OUT
THE DEADLINE FOR A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS TO MEET
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
THRESHOLD TO MAINTAIN THEIR
MAXIMUM CAL GRANT TUITION AWARD.
AT NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR
DOLLARS BY ONE YEAR SO THEY NOW
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO RAMP
UP THE AT T. PATHWAY FOR
STUDENTS PURSUING -- THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
HAVE AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NEEDED THE MUSICIAN DOES CONTAIN
A NUMBER OF ONE TIME PROPOSALS
FOR THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
I'LL BE SPEAKING TO THE THREE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE LISTED ON
PAGE SIX OF YOUR AGENDA.
THE MOST NOTABLE OF THESE
PROPOSALS FOR FUTURE SERVICE
CREDIT SCHOLARSHIP.
AT ABOUT NINETY MILLION ONE TIME
THIS IS AMONG THE LARGEST NAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR EDUCATION
AND AS A RESULT WE THINK IT
MERITS FOR THE CONSIDERATION
FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELL THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS NOT YET
FINAL WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
BASED ON THE INFORMATION
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
OUR CONCERNS PRIMARILY RELATE TO
WHTHER THE PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE
A SUSTAINED IMPACT ON THE FUTURE
WORK FORCE.
AS WELL AS WHETHER THE INCENTIVE
IT CREATES AS WELL TIMED AND
OFTEN HAVE TEACHERS CREDIT
DECISION.
THE STATE HAS PREVIOUSLY FUNDED
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE SIMILAR
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TEACHERS IN
SHORTAGE AREAS.
MOST NOTABLY THE ASSUMPTION
PROGRAM PLANS FOR EDUCATION
ADMINISTERED DID STUDENT AID
COMMISSION PREVIOUSLY.
WE THINK THAT THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THESE PROGRAMS
COULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
STRENGTHEN THIS PROPOSAL.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WHERE TO
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL IN SOME
FORM WE THINK IT MAY ALSO WISH
TO DIRECT THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION REPORT AND PROGRAM
OUTCOMES HAS THIS INFORMATION
COULD GUIDE FUTURE DECISIONS
ABOUT USING THIS TYPE OF
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE. TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES.
SECONDLY IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOTED THE MERE VISION
DOES ALSO IDENTIFIED A STUDENT A
COMMISSION IS THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADMINISTER THE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT GRANT PROGRAM.
WHICH THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD LAST
MONTH.
WHEN THIS PROPOSAL RESEMBLES AN
EXISTING INITIATIVE CREATED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CALLED
EVERY KID COUNTS ALSO
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE STATE
MADE COMMISSION?
AS THE STUDENT A QUESTION JUST
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE GRANTEES
REPLICATE COUNTS WE THINK THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED PREMATURE TO
CREATE A NEW INITIATIVE BEFORE
WE HAVE SOME SHORT TERM OUTCOMES
LESSONS AND FROM THE EXISTING.
ONE FINALLY THE MERRY VISION
TRANSFERS FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
FOR STUDENT LOAN AWARENESS
ACTIVITIES FROM THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION.
GIVEN THE FIRST ACTIVITIES OF
YOUR DUPLICATE EFFORTS FROM THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE SECOND FOR THE COLLEGES.
AND ALSO VERIFY FOR SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
REJECTED PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE TABLE IN
FRONT OF ME YES SIR.
GOOD MORNING DAVID O'BRIEN WITH
A CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION AS ALWAYS WHEN I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
WORKING WITH US ON REVISED
ESTIMATES OF OUR CAL GRANT
SPENDING VERY COMPLEX PROGRAM
WITH PROJECTIONS AND ESTIMATES
THAT -- DO FLUCTUATE FROM
JANUARY TO MAY SO -- THEY'VE
BEEN VERY HELPFUL -- WE HAVEN'T
HAD TIME TO COMPLETE A FULL
ANALYSIS OF THE NEW PROPOSALS IN
THE MAY REVISE JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT AND YOU KNOW OVERALL WE
APPRECIATE THE NEW INVESTMENTS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION IN COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
THAT THIS BUDGET REFLECTS -- AND
WE STILL WORK LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
LEGISLATORS ON A COMPREHENSIVE
FINANCIAL AID REFORM I DO WANT
TO NOTE -- ONE ITEM THAT I COULD
AT LEAST BE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE SOME CONCERNS OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAD RAISED.
WHICH I THE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS WHEN -- I WAS HERE A
WEEK OR TWO AGO -- THAT MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAD
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN THAT THE
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT WERE
RUNNING -- IT DIDN'T INCLUDE
PROGRAMS IN SOME REGIONS OF THE
STATE -- AND THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE EVERY KID COUNTS
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE CURRENT
PROGRAM.
DID NOT ALLOW FOR THE FUNDS TO
BE USED FOR START UP FOR SORT OF
JUMP START FUNDS AND THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE REVISED.
INCLUDE A SPECIFIC SET ASIDE
ABOUT THREE QUARTERS OF THE
FUNDS PARTY'S DESIGNATED FOR NEW
PROGRAMS TO SORT OF HELP THEM
GET OFF THE GROUND SO -- WITH
ANY LUCK IF IT WERE TO BE
APPROVED WE WOULD -- WANT TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICES AND WITH
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS LEADING
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SO FORTH
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
COVERING MORE REASONS OF THE
STATE INCLUDING THOSE THAT --
THAT MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HAD MENTIONED AT THE LAST
HEARING ON THIS.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
REGARDING THE LA OWES.
ANALYSIS OF I GUESS IT WAS THE
TEACHERS SERVICE CREDIT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
IN THE COMMENTED PROSPECTIVE
APPLICANTS WOULD NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE PROGRAM BEFORE THEY
DECIDE WHICH SUBJECT HERE ISN'T
SCHOOLS TO TEACH AND AND THE
FOLLOWING COMMENTS ABOUT HOW
THAT MAY NOT BE POSSIBLE.
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN -- AND WE WOULD WANT --
TO PROBABLY WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS SOME ALLOWANCE IN THE
LANGUAGE -- IF THERE'S A DESIRE
TO DO SO FROM -- FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SOME OUTREACH
ON THE FRONT END -- SO WE'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SEE IF -- TO
SEE IF THAT CONCERN CAN BE
ADDRESSED FINANCE WAS THAT JUST
SIMPLY AN UNINTENDED.
DEVELOPMENT SO I I THINK THE
KIND OF ONE IMPORTANT FACTOR OF
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE DO REQUIRE
THIS YOU NEED COMMISSION TO WORK
WITH THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. TO KIND OF
IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE BEST
OPPORTUNITIES TO REACH TEACHERS
TO INFORM THEIR DECISION FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE
THIS PROPOSAL ISN'T NECESSARILY
ABOUT TACKLING THE LARGE TEACHER
SHORTAGE THAT EXIST IN THE STATE.
BUT RATHER IT'S A ONE TO PURSUE
TEACHING THAT'S SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN SCHOOL SITES THAT HAVE HIGH
NUMBERS OF PROVISIONAL OR
CONDITIONAL WAIVERS.
SO IN OTHER WORDS ARE YOU SAYING
THIS.
THE TEACHERS ARE GOING TO BE
WHERE THEY ARE AND AND AND
THEY'RE GONNA QUALIFY WHERE THEY
ARE.
A NOT NECESSARILY I THINK I
THINK THE POINT IS OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE TWO
COMMISSIONS WORKING TOGETHER
WILL DEVELOP.
A LIST OF WHICH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF THESE
PROVISIONAL WAIVERS AND PERMITS.
AND HEN BASED ON THAT THEY'LL
PRIORITIZE AWARDING THE GRANTS
TO STUDENTS WERE TEACHING IN
HIGH PRIORITY AREAS SUCH AS STEM
FIELDS OUT THOSE SCHOOL SITES.
I SEE.
AND IF I MAY ADD TO THAT DRUG
JUST BEFORE THIS HEARING AID
NOTIFIED YOUR STAFF THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE FOR THIS PROPOSAL.
AND WILL ATTEMPT TO GET THAT
YOUR STAFF AS QUICKLY IN ITS
EXPOSITION EXPEDITIOUSLY AS WE
CAN [inaudible]
PERFECT.
ANYTHING FURTHER ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS THEIR
LEVEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE HAPPY MONDAY.
I HAVE A QUESTION -- I BELIEVE
IN THE SPIRIT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FUNDS FOR RAPID --
RESPONSE FOR HOMELESS AND THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF IN OF OUR IN
SECURE STUDENTS.
BUT I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT IT
DOESN'T GO TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND WE'RE
NOT HELPING STUDENTS THAT NEED
IT THE MOST.
SOME WONDERING AND I'M NOT SURE
WHO ARE ONCE ANSWER THE QUESTION
CAN -- WHAT THE RATIONALE IS FOR
EXCLUDING LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS?
OR ACTUALLY ONCE THAT ARE FACING
THE HIGHEST NON TUITION COSTS.
AND SO THE THE PROPOSAL IS SIDE.
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIANS
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY --
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE NOT
INCLUDED WITHIN THAT PROPOSAL --
BASED UPON THE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES WITHIN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SO I DON'T THINK IT
WAS NECESSARILY.
A JUDGMENT CALL AS TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF RAPID RE
HOUSING -- FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATION SO MUCH AS IT WAS THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES WITHIN THE
GUARANTEE.
SO IT.
IS THERE MORE MONEY IMPROPER
NINETY EIGHT THAT I DIDN'T SEE
THAT'S GOING TO HELP THEM.
NO I THINK WHAT WHAT WERE
INSINUATING IT'S THAT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY PACKAGE
GLOBALLY.
IT WAS VERY TIGHT THIS YEAR AND
DIDN'T ENABLE US.
TO MAKE THAT TYPE OF INVESTMENT
AT THIS TIME.
OKAY -- EVEN THOUGH THERE PUBLIC
THE ONES THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
YEAH I WOULD CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS A NEED
IN THE SYSTEM OKAY SO IS THERE
ANY OTHER.
ANOTHER APPROACH THAT WE CAN
TAKE HOW DO WE HELP THESE
STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW I MEAN I MEAN IF I WAS
A STUDENT I WAS JUST LOOK AT MY
CELL THEY'RE GIVING ME THE UC'S
AGREEMENT THIS ISSUES BUT THEY
JUST CLEARLY DON'T CARE ABOUT ME
AS A COMMUNICATOR STUDENT.
SO I THINK WE'LL CRTAINLY WORK
WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES I
KNOW IN THE PAST THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN ALTERNATIVES -- THAT HAVE
BEEN LEGISLATIVELY CONSIDERED --
SUCH AS EMERGENCY GRANTS --
THINGS OF THAT NATURE OF WE'VE
ALSO HEARD IN THAT BILL LAST I
BELIEVE IT WAS LAST SESSION THAT
THERE WAS A BILL TO THAT.
AFFECT THE WOULD ALSO SAY THAT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISN'T
PRECLUDED FROM USING SOME OF ITS
FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE --
THERE'S A A A CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE LEGAL INTERPRETATION THEN.
AT THIS TIME INDICATES THAT THEY
CAN'T DO SO.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT BUT HOPE WE CANNOT
FIGURE SOMETHING OUT FOR THE
STUDENTS -- AND I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE ONE
TIME FIVE MILLION BECAUSE THE
TWO AREAS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
MOST LIKELY IMPACTED BY THAT.
IS THE INLAND EMPIRE -- WHICH IS
MY DISTRICT AND CENTER RAS
DISTRICT AND THEN ALSO THE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO IF IF WE'RE IT
IT. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS MAY NOT
SEEM LIKE A LOT BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
STUDENTS THAT WE REPRESENT SO I
WOULD WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
FIVE MILLION.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE QUESTIONS. ZERO OKAY
LET'S GO ON TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- TWO THIS IS -- ITEM
SIXTY ONE HUNDRED DEPRIVED OF
EDUCATION AND THE MORE.
WHO'S COVERING THE UCC ISSUE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK.
TWICE AS EVERYTHING ELSE.
YES CENTER AND SALAS YOU NUMBER
ONE TO ME SO.
CONTINUE AND IT ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THAT.
THE MAY REVISION CONTINUES THE
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING AND ONE TIME
INVESTMENT TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND THEN MAKES.
A FEW OF AMENDMENTS -- FIRST
ADJUSTMENT WE ARE PROPOSING IN A
REVISION AS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
UC'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RETIREMENT PLAN -- WE
ARE ALSO PROVIDING THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR DYSLEXIA SCREENING
PILOT OPERATED BY THE UCSF
DYSLEXIA CENTER.
THIS PILOT WILL LEVERAGE YOU ADD
NEW TECHNOLOGICAL APPLICATION TO
IDENTIFY LEARNING DISABILITIES
EARLIER.
AND SUPPORT INTERVENTIONS.
ARE ALSO PROPOSING THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR RAPID RE HOUSING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE MAYOR VISION IS A
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL CLARITY AS
TO THE USES OF THE EXISTING
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL FORCED TO
ADDRESSED IN HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS.
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFYING USES
INCLUDING FOOD PANTRIES.
CAL FRESHMAN ROLE MET MEAL
DONATION PLANS AND AND SPECIFIC
EFFORTS TO REDUCE STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS -- CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATION FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- THE MAY REVISION ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE YOU SEE THESE
FIVE MILLION OF THE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. TO CONDUCT OF A
PLAN FACILITIES ASSESSMENT --
WHILE WE'RE ON THE UC UC
HASTINGS I WILL BE RECEIVING
FIVE OR NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND ONE TIMES FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF YOU SEE PATH.
AND THE MARRIAGE AND ALSO
EXPANDS THE AUTHORIZED USES OF
ITS ONE MILLION.
IN A ONE TIME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING TO INCLUDE
CLASSROOM UPGRADES IN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS.
WILL THE ASSESSMENT ALSO INCLUDE --
IN ADDITION.
TO WHAT WE WOULD NORMALLY
CONSIDER DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
OF THE SIZE AND MAGNITUDE OF THE
SEISMIC RETROFIT THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
IF ANY.
IN THE UC SYSTEM.
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENT
DOES NOT THIS PARTICULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENT WILL
NOT BE FOR THE SEISMIC STUDIES
BUT WE ARE CONDUCTING DOT
SEPARATELY.
WHEN WHEN DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO
BE COMPLETED?
I THE REASON I ASK IS I'VE SPENT
SIX YEARS ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE DEALING WITH HOSPITALS
AND SEISMIC IN.
IN LISTENING TO THIS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AT C. ISSUE
IN.
UC'S SINCE I'VE HAD THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IT OCCURRED TO ME
THE OTHER DAY WHEN I HAD
HASTINGS IN HERE TO ASK.
HOW THEY WERE DOING FROM A
SEISMIC STANDPOINT SO I I WANT
TO INCLUDE THAT IN MY?
RANGE OF QUESTIONS AND NOT TO
PUT ANY PRESSURE ON AS YOU DO
COMPLETE THE STUDY OF LIKE TO
SEE A COPY OF THE REPORT GO TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF SO WE CAN
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF SEISMIC
REPAIR.
AND RENOVATION REPLACEMENT AS AS
NECESSARY YES CENTER ROTH ALL
MAKE CERTAIN THAT YOUR STAFF
HAVE A COPY OF THAT REPORT WHEN
IT BECOMES AVAILABLE.
THE REGION'S DID ADOPT A POLICY
THAT STATES THAT ALL OF THE UC
BUILDINGS HAVE TO BE REASSESSED
BY -- TWENTY THIRTY SO I'M NOT
CERTAIN EXACTLY WHAT OUR TIME
LINE EVERYBODY DID THE CAN IS
THERE A WAY TO GET A BETTER
ASSESSMENT ON THE SEISMIC
SITUATION BEFORE TWENTY THIRTY
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
FROM NOW.
POTENTIALLY S. OF I I WILL CHECK
IN WITH OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY FOLKS
AND GET YOUR DATE BY WHEN WE
EXPECT THE STUDY TO BE COMPLETE
I DON'T WANT TO PUT YOU ON THE
HOT SEAT I MEAN.
THERE'S SEVERAL SEVERAL CAMPUSES
DON'T NEED TO WORRY THEY THEY
HAVE TO BUY LIFE BOATS BUT
OTHERS YOU NO NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT SEISMIC ISSUES AND I THINK
WE OUGHT TO HAVEWE AT LEAST IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
I HAVE AN IDEA OF HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE LOOKING AT SO WE CAN PLAN
ON HOW TO GET IT DONE --
PROBABLY SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER THANK YOU THOUGH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HELLO.
SURE IF IT'S UNLESS YOU'D LIKE
TO INCLUDE CSU AND THEN GO TO
THE LA OR IF YOU'D LIKE TO COVER
YOU SEE ISSUES FINE PERFECT.
I DON'T HAVE A BATTING ORDER ON
HERE SO PLEASE JUMP IN AND SWING
CERTAINLY WILL WELL AT THE THE
CSU IN AS WELL -- THERE IS THE
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR RAPID RE HOUSING
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY NOTED
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY ROTATION
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
FOR SUPPORTER PROJECT REBOUND
THIS WOULD TAKE IT TO A TOTAL OF
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THOSE EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
KNOWING THAT THERE GRANT FUNDING
IS RUNNING OUT A SORE INTENT IS
TO PROVIDE TO A STABLE LEVEL OF
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS TO
CONTINUE -- WE HAVE ALSO ADDED
LANGUAGE AROUND THE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CAMPUS STUDY IN
SAN JOAQUIN LIKELY STOCKTON --
AND THEN LASTLY IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENTS THERE IS A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT.
A FIRST STAR FOSTER YOUTH COHORT
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SACRAMENTO.
THIS IS A FOUR YEAR PROGRAM PER
GENERALLY COHORT OF ROUGHLY
THIRTY STUDENTS -- THEY MEET
ONCE A MONTH IN THE SUMMER AS
WELL AS EVERY SATURDAY -- HAS
THE LA -- HIS NOTED IN THEIR
ANALYSIS THERE HAVE BEEN
POSITIVE RESULTS OF FOR FOSTER
YOUTH THAT HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THAT PROGRAM.
AND THEN THERE ARE TWO PIECES OF
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE -- THAT
ARE RATHER CONFORMING TO PAST
ACTIONS.
OKAY MY COMMENTS ABOUT SEISMIC
TO USE THE APPLY.
TO THE ISSUE IS WELL I'D LIKE TO
HAVE A AT SOME POINT GET AN IDEA.
A HANDLE ON HOW MUCH WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND WHERE WE NEED TO
DO IT AND IN WHAT TIME FRAME.
FOR THE C. ISSUES AS WELL.
OKAY NOW WE'RE READY FOR RELEASE.
YOUR OWN SER RATE AND ALL SPEAK
TO THE UC PROPOSALS FIRST AND
THEN MY COLLEAGUE POSTING HOUSE
AND WILL SPEAK TO THE CSU
PROPOSALS.
IF THAT'S HELPFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR ON THE THE KEY YOU SEE
PROPOSALS ON PAGE TWO OF YOUR
AGENDA.
AND ALL DISCUSS THE FIRST TWO
PROPOSALS ON THAT THE THIRD
PROPOSAL FOR RAPID RE HOUSING IS
COMPARABLE TO A PROPOSAL FOR CS
USE WITHOUT IT BE HELPFUL FOR
YOU FOR THE CSU PORTION JUST.
MENTION THAT ONE TIME TO TO SAY
THE COMMITTEE SOMETIME THERE.
ON THE FIRST PROPOSAL FOR A YOU
SEE OUR P..
WE THINK THIS RAISES A FEW
ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS A IS A RATHER
BROAD ISSUE AND IT'S ISSUE THAT
YOU FACE EACH YEAR AS OUR DECIDE
DECIDING HOW TO ALLOCATE ONE
TIME FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S VARIOUS LIABILITIES.
OTHER STATE FUNDS THREE
DIFFERENT PENSION SYSTEMS
CALPERS CAL STIRS AND USE YOUR
P. AND THERE'S A BROAD QUESTION
YOUR FACE BUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING AMONG THOSE THREE
SYSTEMS.
WHAT APPROACH AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BE TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING?
A TO CALPERS AND CAL STIRS FIRST.
THE RATIONALE BEHIND THAT
APPROACH WOULD BE THAT THE STATE
DIRECTLY ADOPTION PENSION
BENEFITS IN THE FUNDING POLICIES
FOR THE SYSTEMS.
I THOUGHT EITHER A CLEAR ROLE IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING THE
REMAINING UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
RESULTING FROM UNDER FUNDING THE
PENSION SYSTEM BY CONTRAST I
EASY THE UC REGENTS ADOPT THE
PENSION BENEFITS.
I'M IN THE FUNDING POLICY FOR
YOU SEE OUR P. NO THAT'S SAID
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT STILL WANT.
TO ADDRESS SOME COST PRESSURES
THAT YOU SEE YOU MIGHT WANT TO
PROVIDE SOME ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THAT UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITY.
OUR SECOND CONSIDERATION IS THAT
IF YOU IF THAT WAS THE GOAL OF
THE LEGISLATURE WE RECOMMEND
THAT YOU GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS POTENTIAL SAVINGS RESULTING
FROM THIS APPROPRIATION.
OF THE LEGISLATURE AS OF YET
HASN'T RECEIVED AN ESTIMATE OF
THE ASSOCIATED SAVINGS OF
PROVIDING THE ONE TIME FUNDING.
THE THIRD CONSIDERATION IS IF
YOU WERE TO PROVIDE FUNDING YOU
COULD ALSO CONSIDER.
A DOUBLE CHIN SOME SORT OF MATCH
WITH UC'S NON STATE OF FUNDS
SOURCES.
THE REASON FOR THAT IS USE YOUR
PIECE.
ABOUT TEN BILLION DOLLAR
UNFUNDED LABILITY IT REFLECTS
THE LIABILITY ACROSS BOTH ITS
CORE BUDGET AND ITS NON CORE
BUDGET INCLUDING ITS MEDICAL
CENTERS -- HOUSING AND DINING
PROGRAMS.
I'M INTO SOME SORT OF MATCH
WOULD REFLECT THE THOSE NON
STATE SOURCES ALSO SHARING AND
CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR PORTION OF
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY -- BASED
ON PAST CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
WE'VE HAD WITH YOU SEE WE
THOUGHT AS A VERY ROUGH RULE OF
THUMB.
I WANTED A TWO DOLLAR MATCH
EVERYONE DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
COULD BE REASONABLE SO IF YOU
WERE APPROPRIATE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
OF YOU CAN EXPECT A MATCH FROM
THE UNIVERSITY ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS BUT YOU COULD
WORK WITH THE UNIVERSITY TO
REFINE THAT OF MATCHING
EXPECTATION MORE IF THAT WAS OF
INTEREST TO THE COMMITTEE.
KAMALA LET ME JUST MAKE SURE I
GET THIS.
SO WE'RE GOING.
TO WE'RE GOING TO PAY DOWN SOME
UNFUNDED LIABILITY YOU SEE
RETIREMENT.
THE UC RETIREMENT SYSTEM HAS
SOME COMPONENTS ONE OF THE I
GUESS THE FACULTY.
THE STAFF ON THE THE NON HEALTH.
CAMPUS CAMPUSES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE
EMPLOYED ON THE HEALTH SIDE IF
YOU SEE YOU SEE HELPS OF
PHYSICIANS.
NURSES ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS [inaudible]
WIRE WHEEL.
THE HEALTH SIDE OF THE UC.
GENERATES A FIRM -- CASH FLOW MY
RECOLLECTION.
IS FROM SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE
LAST TIME I SAW THE FINANCIALS
FOR THE HEALTH SYSTEMS SITES.
WHY ARE WE?
DEALING WITH THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY FOR THE HEALTH SYSTEMS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT TO UNTANGLE --
THE CORE NON CORE PORTION OF THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
IN PAST YEARS WE'VE IT SOUNDS
LIKE A AS A RUFFLE FROM ABOUT A
THIRD.
OF THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY COULD
BE A SORT OF SO SEATED WITH THE
CORE BUDGET.
I'M I WISH I COULDN'T WE
COULDN'T THINK OF ANOTHER
MECHANISM THAT WOULD JUST
ISOLATE THAT CORE PORTION OF THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OTHER THAN
SORT OF EXPECTING THAT MATCH
THAT'S FOR THE MATCHING
RECOMMENDATION COMES FROM -- BUT
IN THE PAST YEARS THE STATE
HASN'T EXPECTED THAT MATCH THOSE
RESULTS THE STATE OF PROVIDED
FOR EXAMPLE PROPOSITION TWO
FUNDS TO HELP ADDRESS THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
AND OUR UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO ADDRESS THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN SOME TIRED
IT'S BENEFITTED BOTH OF THE CORE
AND NON CORE PORTIONS OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET.
THAT'S A KEY QUESTION FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER IS THERE A WAY THAT YOU
CAN.
I AM SURE THAT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THAT.
UC'S NON STATE FUNDS ARE ALSO
CONTRIBUTING TO THAT AND THAT'S
WHERE THE MATCHING.
A CONSIDERATION COMES FROM.
I GUESS THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD BE
TO HAVE THE HEALTH SYSTEMS.
DUMP IN SOME MONEY TO PAY DOWN
THE UNFUNDED LIABILITY FROM
WITHIN YOU SEE.
AND THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WORDS
SUGGESTING YOU COULD CONSIDER IS
HAVING SOME SORT OF MATCH TO THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WELL I'M
SURE.
YOU SEEN AND I'LL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATION IN A MINUTE BUT I
MEAN JUST MAKE SURE HE'S HE'S
FINISHED HE FINISHED.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
THE SECOND OF A BULLET POINT
THERE ON PAGE TWO WHICH IS THE
DYSLEXIA CENTER.
WE THINK THEREFORE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE FIRST IS -- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS PILOT
IS -- TO DEVELOP NEW WAYS TO
TEST AND ADDRESS STUDENTS WHO
HAVE -- DYSLEXIA AND OTHER FORMS
OF LEARNING DISABILITIES THE
PILOT WOULD BE AT A AT A AT A
SELECT NUMBER OF SCHOOLS WITH
THE ULTIMATE INTENTION OF ON
LEARNING THE RESULTS OF THE
PILOT AND THEN HOPEFULLY SCALING
IT UP STATEWIDE TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE PILOT IS SUCCESSFUL.
THE FOUR CONSIDERATIONS WE HAVE
WHAT WHAT ITS FIRST THAT -- WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE I
WORK WITH THE MOST
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS PILOT WHEN INTERACT WITH
THE STATE'S EXISTING SPECIAL
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE SOFAS AND
THE REAP REGIONAL DIAGNOSTIC
CENTERS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- TO HELP IN
THE TESTING AND AND EDUCATING OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE.
LEARNING DISABILITIES.
THE SECOND CONSIDERATION IS --
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE --
WORK WITH ADMINISTRATION
UNDERSTAND KIND OF THE ULTIMATE
END GAME OF THE PILOTS OF THE
GOOD FOR GOAL IS TO SCALE IT
WHAT WOULD BE THE PLAN TO SCALE
IT AND WOULD THAT ENTAIL ANY.
ONGOING OR FUTURE COSTS ON THE
ON THE STATE.
THIRD OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THIS UCSF CENTER HAS RAISED TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY.
AND SO IN ADDITIONAL QUICK
CONSIDERATION IS WHETHER THOSE
FUNDS COULD GO TO SUPPORT BY
THIS AND OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT
THAT CENTER HAS IN THE UP COMING
FISCAL YEAR.
AND IN FOURTH I IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE INTERESTED IN
IN IN IN ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE ALSO RECOMMEND SOME
REPORTING LANGUAGE BUT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND THE
RESULTS OF THE PILOT.
THANK YOU GOT IT.
OKAY WHO'S NEXT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE ME SAY
OVER TEN IN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS --
RECOGNIZED UNIVERSITIES FUNDING
NEEDS AND PROVIDED US WITH MORE
FUNDING IN THE MAY REVISE -- IN
REGARDS TO THE LA OWES
RECOMMENDATION ON YOU SEE OUR P.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT IN --
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE UNIVERSITY
IS DEPOSITING ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN TO USE THE
RPG.
FROM EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WHICH FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION COMES FROM CORE FUNDS SO
THE HEALTH CENTERS ARE ALREADY
PUTTING IN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY.
IN READ THOSE NUMBERS AGAIN.
THIS RUN BY THEM ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FROM EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND WAS FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION FROM THE CORE CAMPUS SO
THAT'S THE INSTRUCTIONAL SIDE
WITH THE FACULTY AND STAFF WAS
SERVED TO STUDENTS.
NOW DO DOES ANY PORTION OF THAT
CONSTITUTE A PAID OUT OF
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OR IS THAT
SIMPLY -- REQUIRED PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS APPROXIMATELY 6%
OF THAT IS UNFUNDED LIABILITY
PAY DOWN.
I DON'T SORRY I DON'T HAVE MY
CALCULATOR IN FRONT OF ME TO
TELL YOU THAT 6% AS I'M IN A
DISH AND THAT THOSE FUNDS WE ARE
CURRENTLY PLANNING ANOTHER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTION IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY FROM STEP FUNDS
STEP IS OUR SHORT TERM
INVESTMENT POOL WHERE WE RECEIVE
SOME INTEREST AND THOSE ARE
GOING TO GO INTO UC RP TO PAY
DOWN UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
SO UNIVERSITY BELIEVES THAT WE
ARE ALREADY OF PROVIDING A MATCH
THROUGH DOT [inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION --
THREE MOVE ON TO THE RAPID RE
HOUSING OR D. DYSLEXIA CENTER
YOUR CHOICE MA'AM -- CHECK A
LITTLE ISSUE TALK ME THROUGH IT.
OKAY I'LL MOVE ON TO THE
DYSLEXIA CENTER SINCE YOU HEARD
THE HORN COVERED OF WE'RE WE'RE
FINE WITH PROVIDING A REPORT. TO
THE COMMITTEE OF WE DO BELIEVE
THAT -- DYSLEXIA IS -- OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
EXCELLENT FACULTY WHO CAN ASSIST
THE IN CREATION OF THIS PILOT
PROGRAM. TO CREATE OF METHODS
FOR TEACHERS TO IDENTIFY A
DYSLEXIC STUDENTS AND HELP THE
STUDENTS EXCEL UNFORTUNATELY
STUDENTS WITH DYSLEXIA ARE OFTEN --
THOUGHT OF BY TEACHER SOMETIMES
AS LAZY OR STUPID BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TROUBLE READING AND WRITING --
AND BY IDENTIFYING THOSE
STUDENTS EARLY WE CAN HELP THEM
EXCEL.
SO ARMED WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
YOU APPROVED THOSE FUNDS.
ON THE RAPID RE HOUSING WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
RECOGNIZED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEED -- ARE MY
LATEST STUDENTS SURVEY DID
INDICATE THAT 5% OF OUR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS SOMETIME
DURING THE YEAR MANY OF THEM
DURING THE WINTER BREAK AND
SUMMER.
OF 5% OF YOU SEE STUDENTS IS
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
SO THERE IS A LOT OF NEED SO WE
REQUEST THAT YOU APPROVED THESE
FUNDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
IF IT'S OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST MAKE A QUICK CLARIFICATION
ON THE USE YOUR P. ISSUE ONE
AGAIN YES JUST ON THE OF FUNDING
SOURCES THAT THE UNIVERSITY WALK
THROUGH.
WE JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
AS THE UNIVERSITY NOTED -- IT'S
FUNDING IT'S BOTH IT'S A EARNED
BENEFITS EACH YEAR END OF THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THROUGH TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS THE FIRST OF
THROUGH THE REGULAR.
EMPLOYEE AN EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WHICH IT SHARES
BETWEEN CORE NON CORE FUNDING.
BUT ALSO IS HAS BORROWING TO
COVER THE REMAINDER OF THAT.
SOME OF THE BORROWING HAS BEEN
EXTERNAL BORROWING AND SOME OF
THAT HAS BEEN INTERNAL BORROWING
FROM IT'S FUN SOURCES.
THE UNIVERSITY THEN PAYS THE
ASSOCIATED DEBT FROM THAT
BORROWING AGAIN SHARING.
FROM ITS CORE AND NON CORE
BUDGETS.
AND SO ARE OUR POINT WAS ONLY
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE'RE SHARING THESE COSTS.
IF THE LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED
AND PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ON TOP OF THAT WOULD ALSO MAKE
SENSE TO CONTINUE THAT SCHERING --
CONCEPT WITH THE WITH THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO WE COVER EVERYBODY AT THE
TABLE.
IN THIS ISSUE I MISSED YOU.
YES SIR SO AUSTIN AS AND GET ON
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE -- COMMENT ON THE RAPID
RE HOUSING PROPOSAL WHICH
CROSSES THE BOTH.
IN FACT BOTH UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY I CAN ALSO.
MENTION THE THE FOSTER YOUTH.
PROPOSED PROGRAM AT CSU WHICH IS
ON PAGE FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA.
SO THAT WITH REGARD TO THE RAPID
RE HOUSING PROPOSALS PROPOSAL
REYES RAISES SEVERAL ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS A WIDELY
USED APPROACH FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS.
AMONG.
PLEASE VETERANS AND OTHER
POPULATIONS.
IT S THAT EXPENSIVE -- COSTLY
MODEL.
THAT'S SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND
THE MODEL USUALLY ENTAILS
HELPING TO PAY THE RENT. FOR
CLIENTS AND PROVIDING A CASE
MANAGER.
A HIGH TOUCH -- CASE MANAGEMENT
APPROACH SO IT IS EXPENSIVE IN
THE PROPOSED LEVEL FUNDING.
IN THE MAY REVISE LIKELY WOULD.
THUS ONLY HELP A SMALL
PROPORTION OF NEEDY STUDENTS AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY THE
ASK IT COULD.
SOMEBODY KEEP IN MIND IS A COULD
CREATE SOME COST PRESSURES ON
THE LEGISLATURE.
TO INCREASE FUNDING YOU KNOW
ANNUALLY TO ADDRESS THIS NEED.
AS THE AGENDA NOTES AND THE
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD IN HEARINGS
EARLIER THIS SPRING -- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A SEPARATE
BASIC NEEDS.
A PROPOSAL SET OF PROPOSALS FOR
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY ITS
ONGOING THIS PROPOSED FOR YOU
SEE AND ONE TIME FOR CSU.
SO SOMETHING ELSE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TO KEEP IN MIND
WHEN IT.
THINKING THROUGH THE RAPID RE
HOUSING PROPOSAL IS [inaudible]
HOW?
THE PROPOSALS IN JANUARY AND
THEN THIS NEW PROPOSAL IN MAY
HOW THESE PROGRAMS WOULD
INTERACT WHETHER YOU WOULD WANT
TO BE SURE THAT THEY WOULD WORK
IN A COHESIVE.
COHERENT WAY AS OPPOSED TO KIND
OF A SET A SILO TO APPROACH AND
SO BETTER.
UNDERSTANDING BEING REASSURED
THAT THERE ARE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE GOING TO WORK TOGETHER.
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES DECIDE.
TO FIND.
THE RAPID RE HOUSING.
PROGRAM.
LEGISLATURE'S GONNA NEED A LOT
MORE INFORMATION CURRENTLY
THERE'S JUST NOT MUCH LANGUAGE
ON THIS PROPOSALS THE
LEGISLATURE WANNA UNDERSTAND
MUCH BETTER.
WHAT EXACTLY IS MEANT BY RAPID
RE HOUSING?
HOW CAMPUSES WOULD BE SELECTED
TO HAVE A PROGRAM HOW STUDENTS
WOULD BE SELECTED HOW THE MONEY
WOULD GO OUT?
AND WHAT SORT OF A REPORTING OR
OTHER OVERSIGHT WITH THE PROGRAM --
ENTAILS.
WITH REGARD TO FOSTER USE THIS
IS THE THIRD BULLET POINT ON
PAGE FOUR OF YOUR AGENDA THIS
FIRST OUR FOSTER YOUTH COHORT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
[inaudible]
LIKE.
LIKE THE RAPID RE HOUSING
PROPOSAL THIS MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL.
RAISES THE ISSUE ABOUT HOW MANY
STUDENTS WOULD ACTUALLY BE
SERVED -- AND IN THIS CASE IT
WOULD JUST SERVE.
THIRTY FOSTER YOUTH AND HIGH
SCHOOLS.
AND ONLY IN SACRAMENTO.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF FOSTER YOUTH
CURRENTLY IN HIGH SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALONE THERE'S
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH
CURRENTLY IN HIGH SCHOOL THIS
WOULD AGAIN SERVE.
THIRTY SO THE THE PROPOSAL RACES
EQUITY QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENTS
WHO WOULD NOT BE ONE OF THE
THIRTY CHOSEN -- AND STUDENTS
WHO ARE INCLUDING STUDENTS WHO
LIVE OUTSIDE OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SACRAMENTO AREA.
AND OF COURSE -- WERE THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO WANT TO
EXPAND.
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM THERE
COULD BE SOME OUT YOUR COSTS YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF ON GOING COSTS.
AND COST TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF FOSTER
YOUTH THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO SOME SOME.
ISSUES TO CONSIDER.
WHEN LOOKING AT THESE MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS?
ANY COMMENT.
THE WITH WHAT'S I GUESS ONE OF
THE ISSUES IS WHAT'S THE GOAL IS
IS A PILOT IS.
THE PILOT PROGRAM OF THE STUDY
TO BE EXPANDED OR WELL I'LL HAVE
TO DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THAT AND I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SOME.
OVERARCHING COMMENTS ON BEHALF
THIS ISSUE RIVER WAS TO GO FIRST
IS FINE CERTAINLY SOLDIERS SO ON
THE FIRST OUR FOSTER YOUTH
COHORT I THINK WE'RE CERTAINLY
TARGETING -- SACRAMENTO STATE WE
ARE WHERE THAT CSU SAN BERNADINO
DOES OPERATE ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS TODAY -- SO WERE WERE
LOOKING AT IT AS A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT FOR ONE COHORT -- I
THINK WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
LOOKING OF WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF
THAT COHORT OR BUT IT IS VERY
FOCUSED ON JUST THE ONE
UNIVERSITY AT THIS TIME HOW TO
SIMMER TO HAVE A SIM READINESS
PROGRAM FUNDED.
I THINK WE'RE STILL OUT LOOKING.
WE'RE STILL -- INVESTIGATING HOW
THAT PROGRAM IS FUNDED AT THIS
TIME -- I DON'T KNOW -- BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY GET BACK YOUR
STAFF WITH THE CENTER ROUGHLY.
I THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I HAD A CONVERSATION
LATE LAST WEEK WITH.
A STAFF AT FIRST STAR WHICH IS
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES AND COURT
IN THAT STAFF PERSON.
THE SALMON A DINO CAMPUSES
CAMPUS RECEIVES MONEY FROM THE
LOCAL LOCAL COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND ALSO RECEIVES SOME
PRIVATE MONEY.
PHILANTHROPIC MONEY THROUGH THE
FOUNDATION PROBABLY.
THEY GET AMBERG FOUNDATIONS WHAT
I HEARD.
YES SIR WELL THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME TO YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE AND PROVIDE SOME
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THIS ISSUE
MY NAME AGAIN IS RAINSTORM --
FIRST I WANT TO POINT OUT WE'RE
WILL BURKE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR STICKING WITH
THEIR JANUARY PROPOSAL OF A
PROVIDING A LOT OF FUNDING CORE
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY TO
COVER COMPENSATION -- PORTIONS
OF OUR GRADUATION ISSUED IF
INCREASED ACCESS THOSE SORTS BY
INJURY PORTION OF THAT TOO WE'RE
ALSO VERY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
KEENLY AWARE THAT ARTS.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT NEEDS.
I THAT TRANSCEND JUST THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT THAT'S
THEIR LIVING AND THEIR LIVING.
CONDITIONS AND LIVING EXPENSES
THAT ARE THAT ARE ALSO A
CHALLENGE TO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING --
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO
LEAVE AN IMPRESSION WITH WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND AND I STRESS
THIS ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
WAS THE FACT THAT -- FROM THE
CITY'S PERSPECTIVE OUR OUR FIRST
AND FOREMOST CALISTA FUNDED THE
BALANCE OF OUR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
THERE'S A NEED FOR ANOTHER
THIRTY MILLION OLLARS FOR THAT
INITIATIVE I THINK IF THAT'S
FULLY FUNDED.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER AN
ADDITIONAL COURSE TO AS MANY AS
NINETY THOUSAND DIGITAL STUDENTS
AND THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE GOAL
IS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ACCESS
TO OUR CURRENT STUDENTS.
ON TOP OF THAT THERE'S ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD TO THE TO THE
GLOBAL AMOUNT AGREES THAT THE
CAL THAT CALIFORNIA.
IS ANTICIPATED TO NEED IN THE
NEAR FUTURE RIGHT OUR OUR
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO GO TOWARDS
NEEDING GROWING TOARDS A NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL HIGHER.
I DEGREES OF EDUCATION AND OUR
GOAL IS -- TO INSURE GREATER
ACCESS TO FUTURE STUDENTS ARE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS SO WHAT IT
COMES DOWN TO THESE PROPOSES I
THINK WHAT WILL WHAT WE WE WOULD
SAY GENERALLY SPEAKING IS IS
THAT OUR PRIORITY WOULD BE FOR
OUR CORE REQUEST.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
WE WANT TO ADDRESS OBVIOUSLY BUT
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE LA --
WHERE IF THERE IS THE DESIRE TO
ESTABLISH SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS?
THERE WILL BE THAT A COME KIND
OF A COMPLETE A COMPETITION FOR
LIMITED GENERAL FUND DOLLARS --
FOR NOT ONLY THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT OUR CORE MISSION AS A
AS A UNIVERSITY BUT THEN ALSO AT
ADDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR A
NUMBER OF THESE STUDENTS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES -- AND WITH
THAT I THINK THAT'S THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THE MI
REVISION THANK YOU.
WELL LET ME JUST SAY -- IT WAS
NOT LOST ON SOME OF US WHAT WAS
NOT IN THE MAY REVISION.
AND IT'S A MATTER OF OF
BALANCING PRIORITIES THE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES VERSUS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES
AND AS BERMAN FINANCE KNOWS WELL
WE WILL SORT ALL THAT OUT IN THE
NEXT -- WEEK OR TWO CERTAINLY
UNIFYING HANDED THOSE PRIORITIES
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE ON THE
CSU SAN JOAQUIN STUDY THAT'S A
HIGH PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION [inaudible]
NOTED.
ANYTHING ELSE ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE BEFORE WE MOVE ON I DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE ANYBODY OUT
EVERYBODY GETS TO TALK OKAY.
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER ONE LET'S GO
TO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO THANK YOU ALL EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION.
ITEM SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO AND THEN A REVISION IS K. TO
TWELVE AN EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS.
IT'S THE MORNING GOOD MORNING
SEVERAL BUDDY -- DEN OF FIVE
THEMSELVES -- STARTING TO MY
LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT MA'AM.
LARA MATTOON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WRITTEN THERE ARE CORTES
ELIA.
THEY'RE IN AN AREA FOR A FINANCE.
KENNETH COUPON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHO WANTS TO START?
GO AHEAD AND GET OFF HERE A GOOD
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
GOING TO PROVIDE YOU JUST WITH A
A PRETTY BRIEF OVERVIEW.
OF THE CALCULATION OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AT THE MAYOR VISION
AND SOME OF THE MAJOR -- K.
THROUGH FOURTEEN SPENDING
PROPOSALS ARE WITHIN.
ARE.
THOSE FOR THE CALCULATION
GUARANTEE IS CONCERNED THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES -- AS YOU
PROBABLY HAVE HEARD THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF FUNDING EVER UNDER THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
AT EIGHTY ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS UP FROM ABOUT EIGHTY
POINT SEVEN AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THEN UP FROM SEVENTY
EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION NOW --
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
OF COURSE UP FROM ALL THE WAY UP
FROM FORTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
DURING THE TROUGH OF THE
RECESSION.
I WOULD CONTINUE REVENUE GROWTH
DURING THE RECOVERY COMING OUT
OF THE GREAT RECESSION TOTAL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES NOW THE
MAYOR VISION ARE ESTIMATED TO BE.
AT ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AN INCREASE OF
MORE THAN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN REVENUES.
A TOTAL HAS A SET OF EIGHTY ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GUARANTEE THAT'S A PER PUPIL
EXPENDITURE FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT OF JUST UNDER TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PUPIL AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR PEOPLE OVER THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS.
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FUNDING AND WE GUARANTEE
IS UP ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER.
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD.
WITH FACTOR CHANGES AT THE MAYOR
VISION MOST NOTABLY A DECREASE
AND PER CAPITA PERSONAL INCOME
IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE WILL ALSO NOW
INCLUDE IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
A DEPOSIT INTO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM STABILIZATION ACCOUNT OR
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RAINY DAY RESERVE.
OF THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AS
REQUIRED.
PER THE CONSTITUTIONAL LANGUAGE
OF PROPOSITION.
TWO ON ALSO SIMILAR TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION WILL NOT EXPERIENCE A
REDUCTION IN PRIOR CURRENT YEAR.
APPROPRIATIONS DESPITE DECLINES
IN THE MID MINIMUM GUARANTEE
CALCULATIONS COMPARED TO THE
pBECAUSE WE ARE PROPOSING TO
CONTINUE A MAINTENANCE OFAN
OVER PERFORATION IN THE PRIOR
YEAR.
IT WAS FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS NOW HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
PRIOR YEAR OF AN OVER
PREPARATION -- AND THEN ALSO
CONTINUING YOU SETTLE UP IN THE
CURRENT YEAR TO OFFSET --
OTHERWISE SO UNFUNDED TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OBLIGATIONS
FOR ONGOING PROGRAMS -- IN THIS
CASE -- THE LC FF IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SOME OF THE
MAJOR SPENDING PROPOSAL CHANGES
ON CAPITOL GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
THAT AS YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT IS
DOWN FROM THREE POINT.
FOUR SIX IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
THREE POINT 26% -- SO THE MAYOR
IS AN IS STILL -- CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING ON A DEAL CFF
BUT WITH THAT -- CHANGE -- THE
INCREASE TO THE LCF OVER
NINETEEN KIRK'S USE ME OVER
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN A COMES ON TO
JUST OVER ONE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AS COMPARED TO TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- BUT STILL
BRINGS THE TOTAL INCREASE
FUNDING -- SENSING A CONVULSIVE
FAST -- TOO JUST ABOUT SIXTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
THE SAME AS WAS PROJECTED UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE REVISION ALSO BUILDS UPON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION BY
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM -- BY OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND USING NOW
ONLY ON GOING FUNDS FOR THIS
PURPOSE WHICH WOULD BRING THE
TOTAL OF FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO SIX HUNDRED NINETY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
THE SO INCLUDING LC THEFT THE
THE DECREASE ATTRIBUTABLE TO
COST OF LIVING -- FOR CASUAL
PROGRAMS -- AT THE MAY REVISION
IS ROUGHLY SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SO THE BULK OF THAT IS
THE DECREASE IN LCF -- BRIEFLY
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
THE MAYOR VIEWS IT MAIN
PROVISION PROPOSES THIRTY NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- ALSO
CONTINUES TO FUND THE
COMMUNICATIVE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM AT ITS CURRENT FUNDING
LEVEL OF TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- WITH ALMOST
ALL OF IT THIS TIME -- BEING
FUNDED FROM ONGOING FUNDS AS
COMPARED TO A MIX OF ONE TIME AN
ON GOING AS WAS THE CASE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- AND THEN
SIMILARLY TO THE K. TWELVE SIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING A DECREASE
THEIR OF TWENTY POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FROM NINETY TO
REFLECT THE DECREASE IN COST OF
LIVING.
SOME BRIEF OF MAJOR K. --
FOURTEEN NON PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING PROPOSALS
THAT I WANT TO MENTION JUST KIND
OF IN RECOGNITION OF LIMITED
GROWTH THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING
GUARANTEE.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE DEPOSIT
INTO THE RAINY DAY RESERVE THE
MID THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
THESE FOLLOWING -- PROGRAMS AND
AUGMENTATIONS.
ARE YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD A THREE
BILLION DOLLAR A PROPOSAL FOR
THE CAL STIRS EMPLOYER SHARE
CONTRIBUTION RATE -- WE ARE NOW
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ESTIMATED -- IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TO BRING THE EMPLOYER
SHARE CONTRIBUTION RATE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY FROM -- EIGHTEEN
POINT 1% DOWN ALL THE WAY TO
SIXTEEN POINT 7% SO IT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS ABOUT A 1%
DECREASE AND NOW WE ARE
PROJECTING IT WILL BE A ONE
POINT 4%.
A DECREASE IN NINETEEN TWENTY
ONLY.
OF AND THEN -- ALL AS WELL A IN
AN EFFORT -- TO FURTHER TARGET
THE FUNDS CONTAINED WITHIN THE
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES --
FUNDING PROPOSAL AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- WE'RE
PROPOSING PRODUCE -- THAT
FUNDING FROM SEVEN AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS DOWN TO SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND LASTLY -- JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TEACHER WORK FORCE OF
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN TEACHER WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS FOR VOTE.
NEW TEACHERS AT SCHOOLS WITH A
HIGH NUMBER OF TEACHERS SERVING
ON EMERGENCY PERMITS.
PROVIDE STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS ON
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING.
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES AND SUBJECT
MATTER CONFIDENCE IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND ALSO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
LEADERS HOW WOULD THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
QUALITY MY COLLEAGUES. FOR MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW IF.
YOU'RE THE RIGHT PERSON TO
DIRECT THIS TO BUT WITH REGARD
TO THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROPOSAL.
THE I. S. THIS BEFORE WHEN WE
HAD THE GENERAL HEARING ON THE
SUBJECT.
BUT WHAT IS THE RIGHT WHAT WAS
THE RATIONALE.
TO BECAUSE THE PROGRAM TO BE
DESIGNED AROUND A CONCENTRATION
GRANT FORMULA FOR EXAMPLE MORE
THAN 55% -- FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH FOSTER KIDS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS GIVEN THE FACT
THAT.
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS ARE SPREAD
THROUGHOUT DISTRICTS AROUND THE
STATE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
HAVE 55% OR NOT.
AND DOESN'T THAT CREATE A SYSTEM
OF WINNERS AND LOSERS AND ARE WE
DEAL WITH.
RIGHT I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION SHOVEL DO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- SO THE FUNDING IS
GOING TO LIKE YOU MENTIONED
RIGHT FOCUS ON SCHOOLS WITH OVER
55% SINCE SIMILAR.
TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRAN AND NOW CFF --
AND IT WAS HARD IT THIS WAY
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON LOOKING AT AT
THE COMPOUNDING EFFECTS OF
POVERTY RIGHT -- POVERTY IMPACTS
SO MANY ASPECTS OF A PERSON'S
LIFE IN OF A OF A CHILD'S LIFE
AND SO THE FUNDING IS GOING ON
IN THIS WAY TO FOCUS ON KIND OF
AREAS OF NEED IN THE STATE TO
HAVE THESE HIGH RATES OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND ALSO HIGH RATES OF STUDENTS
WITH OTHER NEEDS SUCH AS LIVING
IN POVERTY AND IN YOU KNOW IN
FOSTER CARE -- AND SO IT'S JUST
AT  DIFFERENT WAY TO KIND OF
TARGET ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO TARGET
AND I GUESS WE'LL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THIS IS WE GRAPPLE WITH
DIFFERENCES IN THE BUDGET.
TO TRY TO RECONCILE THINGS BUT
I'M HAVING DIFFICULTY -- IT'S
ONE LET YOU ALL KNOW CONNECTING
POVERTY WAS WITH THE SPECIAL
NEEDS AND THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS IN THE SPECIAL NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE AND HOW TO DEAL
WITH -- SO I'M I'M REALLY HAVING
A DIFFICULT TIME I MEAN IF WE'RE
TRYING TO RELIEVE POVERTY THERE
OTHER PROGRAMS TO DO THAT I
WOULD THINK IN THIS.
ONE SEEMS TO BE TARGETED TOWARD
DRIVING MORE MONEY TO DOWN TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND INTO
CLASSROOMS TO HELP.
EDUCATE THOSE IN SOME CASES WAS
VERY VERY DIFFICULT. TO DEAL
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND I DON'T
SEE HOW.
I AM HAVING TROUBLE MAKING THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
WITH. 56% FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
FOSTER KIDS AND AND THE SCHOOL
WAS 46%.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS FREE
REDUCE LUNCHEON FOSTER KIDS AND
HOW THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
SPECIAL ED MONEY BUT THAT'S A
COMMENT THAT'S NOT A QUESTION.
I'LL DROP IT.
OKAY WHO'S NEXT -- I'M SORRY.
ZERO CAN I JUST ASK UP.
THE LA L. TWO WAY AND AND HELP
BRIDGE THAT IF YOU WOULD -- YES
WILL QUOTE HE DIDN'T ASK THE
QUESTION BUT I I AM I I NEED YOU
TO HELP BRIDGE IF YOU WOULD IS
IT ALRIGHT IF WE COVER THAT IN
OUR PRESENTATION WE DO HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC THOUGHTS ON THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NO THAT DERAILED A TRAIN LET'S
PUT.
NEXT I DON'T REMEMBER AND THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KENNETH COUPON
WITH THE GENTLEST OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT THAT THE
SERGEANT I JUST DISTRIBUTED.
I THINK MICHAEL TO GET THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVE YOU A GOOD
OVERVIEW OF THIS MAN A REVISION.
OF THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT IT
THERE ARE REALLY THREE KEY
NUMBERS TO KIND OF TELL THE TALE
OF OF THE BUDGET FOR YOU.
I TURNING TO PAGE ONE OF OUR
HAND OUT THE FIRST IS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION.
THAT'S THE TOTAL INCREASE IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE ACROSS THE THREE
BUDGET YEARS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
NINETEEN TWENTY AND SO THAT KIND
OF TELLS YOU HOW MUCH.
NEW FUNDING IS POTENTIALLY ON
THE TABLE FOR THINGS AND
PRIORITIES THAT YOU MIGHT CARE
ABOUT.
MOST OF THAT INCREASE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
IT'S RESULT OF THE INCREASE IN
REVENUE ESTIMATES -- AFTER THE
STATE BUDGET YOU PROBABLY ALL
KNOW THAT APRIL WAS A PRETTY
GOOD MONTHS -- FOR A STATE TAX
COLLECTIONS -- TURNING TO PAGE
TWO I THINK THE OTHER NEXT KEY
NUMBER IS THREE HUNDRED AND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
MILLION THAT'S THE SIZE OF THIS
DEPOSIT.
INTO THE STATE'S PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESERVE I THIS
ISN'T SOMETHING WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION SORT OF LOOKS AT
EVERYTHING AND JUST PICKS A
NUMBER THERE'S A VERY SPECIFIC
SET OF CONSTITUTIONAL FORMULAS
THAT DETERMINE.
THE DEPOSIT.
THEY'RE ALMOST AS COMPLICATED AS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT ITSELF --
BUT THE KEY THINGS THAT REALLY
TRIGGERED A DEPOSIT ARE THE
STATE ARE RECEIVING CAPITAL
GAINS ABOVE THE LONG TERM
AVERAGE OF ABOUT 8% OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUE.
AND THEN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GARRETT HE ITSELF
A GROWING MY QUICKLY ARE BEING
ABOVE THE PRIOR YEAR FUNDING
LEVEL ADJUSTED FOR CHANGES IN
STUDENT ATTENDANCE AND INFLATION
FACTOR.
AND SO THAT THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE DEPOSIT ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT HALF OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX MILLION IN NEW
FUNDING THAT -- IS ASSOCIATED
WITH GROWTH AND A GUARANTEE.
AND THEN THE FINAL NUMBER REALLY
GETS TO THE PROGRAM A COMPONENT
OF THE OF THE ME REVISION.
THIS WITH A BUDGET HAS A HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
BEYOND THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET. FOR THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANT
PROPOSAL AS YOU HEARD IT ALSO
MAKES ALL THAT FUNDING ON GOING
INSTEAD OF RELYING ON A MIX OF
ONE TIME AND I'M GOING FUNDS.
ARE THE TWO MOST NOTABLE
PROPOSALS OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT YOU ALREADY HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THAT PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
PENSION RATE RELIEF IN NINETEEN
TWENTY THE OTHER PROPOSAL I
THINK WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS THE
I CHANGED TO THE KINDERGARTEN
FACILITY GRANT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS A PROPOSAL TO
TARGET THOSE GRANTS A LITTLE BIT
MORE NARROWLY SPECIFICALLY ON
DISTRICTS THAT ARE TRYING TO
CONVERT PART TAKEN A GARDEN
PROGRAMS THE FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
HE'S ALSO PROPOSING A LITTLE BIT
OF A SMALLER -- ALLOTMENT FOR
THAT PROGRAM DOWN FROM SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN
JANUARY TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
UNDER THE MADE THE DECISION.
I PAGE THREE OF OUR HAND OUT IS
REALLY JUST A OVER JUST AN
OVERVIEW OF ALL OF THE SPECIFIC
SPENDING PROPOSALS I'LL BE
TALKING A LOT MORE ABOUT THOSE
AND OVER THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO SO
I WON'T GET INTO THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL HERE.
I TURNING TO PAGE FOUR WE THINK.
THIS MAY REVISION HAS A NUMBER
OF POSITIVE ELEMENTS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT ANALYZING?
A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS W ALWAYS
HAVE TO START WITH THE ESTIMATES
OF THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
AND THOSE ARE DRIVEN -- HAVE A
LOT TO DO WITH WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH STATE GENERAL
FUND REVENUE.
I REVENUE ESTIMATES THIS YEAR
ARE VERY CLOSE TOGETHER -- IN
TERMS OF THE REVENUE THAT
AFFECTS THE GUARANTEE I THINK
WE'RE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
OR SO BELOW THE ADMINISTRATION
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN NINETEEN TWENTY BY.
ANY SORT OF HISTORICAL STANDARD
THAT'S A VERY CLOSE TOGETHER.
MOST OF THE DIFFERENCES IN OUR
ESTIMATES HAVE TO DO WITH -- OUR
OUTLOOK BEING COMPLETED JUST A
LITTLE BIT LATER WE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER -- MORE UPDATED DATA THAN
THE ADMINISTRATION.
I WOULD ALSO JUST HAVE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF MODELING -- THE AFFECTS
OF INITIAL PUBLIC OFFERINGS OF
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES.
YOU PROBABLY KNOW THIS BUT A
PRETTY HOT TOPIC LATELY AND
THAT'S HAS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT ON SOME OF THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES THAT WE HAVE.
ALSO ACROSS THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO NINETEEN TWENTY
PERIOD OUR ESTIMATES OF THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE ARE ONLY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
ABOVE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATE SO JUST A VERY SMALL
FRACTION OF THE FUNDING THAT
SCHOOLS ARE ARE ARE RECEIVING.
WE THINK THE FOR MAKING THE
FIRST DEPOSIT INTO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT -- GIVEN ALL OF THE
COMPLEX CALCULATIONS WE LOOK
PRETTY CLOSELY AT THE NUMBERS TO
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD.
AND WE THINK THAT THEY BUT FROM
AND CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
TO PROPOSITION. TWO FOR THE
FIRST TIME AT THE STATE WILL
REALLY HAVE IT SORT OF A
DEDICATED SOURCE OF FUNDING --
TO HELP SCHOOLS GET THROUGH THE
NEXT SORT OF SLOW DOWN OUR
ECONOMIC RECESSION -- BEYOND
JUST SORT OF GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVES ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE
BUDGET THESE THIS OP PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESERVISTS REALLY
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP SMOOTH OUT
SOME OF THAT VOLATILITY FOR
SCHOOLS.
ALSO I THINK COMPLIMENTS SOME OF
THE OTHER EFFORTS YOU MAKING TO
TRY -- TO BUT THE STATE BUDGET
AND EVEN MORE FIRM FOOTING.
AT IN TERMS OF THE MIX OF ONE
TIME AN ONGOING PROPOSALS WE
THINK THIS MAKE THE VISION IS
GENERALLY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
ACTUALLY PROPOSED SPENDING ABOUT
EIGHTY MILLION MORE ON ON GOING
PROGRAMS AND IT HAD AVAILABLE
AND I'M GOING RESOURCES SO THAT
FELT A LITTLE BIT OF A DEFICIT
INTO THE BUDGET. FOR THE NEXT
YEAR OTHER MAJOR REVISION
ELIMINATES THAT DEFICIT STILL
RELIES ON SOME. ONE TIME FUNDS
TO PAY FOR ONGOING COSTS BUT IT
ALSO HAS SETS ASIDE SOME OTHER
MONEY FOR THINGS THAT AREN'T ON
GOING.
AND SO KIND OF TAKING ALL THOSE
FACTORS TOGETHER IT ACTUALLY HAS
A SMALL SURPLUS OF KIND OF
STRUCTURAL IS WHAT WE THINK OF
AS A STRUCTURAL SURPLUS OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS -- FINALLY ON THAT
CAN OCCUR IN FACILITY GRANT WE
THINK THAT IS ALSO A POSITIVE
STEP -- THE CHANGES.
THAT ARE IN THE MAY REVISION I
THINK WE'LL GET THE PROGRAM --
WHAT CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
CORE OBJECTIVE YOU SET FORTH
WHICH WAS TO ENCOURAGE MORE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS?
COULD ALSO ENCOURAGE MORE LOW
INCOME DISTRICTS TO APPLY GIVEN
THAT THE GOVERNOR WANTS A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THAT MATCH THE LOCAL
MATCH TO BE A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN THE STATE TO PICK UP A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF THE COST.
WE STILL THINK THAT DEMAND FOR
THE PROGRAM PROBABLY WILL BE
LESS THAN SIX HUNDRED MILLION
AND SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO FREE UP FUNDING FOR SOME
OF YOUR OTHER PRIORITIES --
LOWERING THAT AMOUNT WOULD BE A
WE THINK OF VERY REASONABLE
PLACE TO START.
I FINALLY TURNING TO PAGE FIVE
OF HIGHLIGHT JUST TO CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE MAJOR
VERSION.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE REALLY THE
THE BUDGET QUESTION.
STILL REMAINS VERY SMALL -- BY
TYPICALLY.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE THE STATE SET ASIDE
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION KIND
OF AN ONGOING FUNDS FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES.
AND THAT GIVES YOU A GOOD BUDGET
CUSHION IN CASE THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE DECLINES OR SOMETHING
HAPPENS NEXT YEAR THOSE ONE
TIMES FUNDS JUST EXPIRE YOU
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE.
REDUCTIONS IN ONGOING PROGRAMS.
AT THE GOT THE MAY REVISION HAS
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN
KIND OF A A ONE TIME QUESTION.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S VERY SMALL
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
TYPE OF DOWNTURN RECESSION THE
STATE MY EXPERIENCE -- IN THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS AND SO AS YOU
START THINKING ABOUT ALL OF
THESE SORT OF SPECIFIC SPENDING
PROPOSALS.
I WOULD RECOMMEND YOU THINK
ABOUT SHIFTING EVEN MORE FUNDING
TO ONE TIME ACTIVITIES A LITTLE
BIT LESS ON ON GOING PROGRAMS.
AND THEN FINALLY I'LL SPEAK TO
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION PROPOSAL I
KNOW THAT'S A PRETTY HOT TOPIC
THIS YEAR -- WE HAD WE SHARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS I THINK
THAT YOU REYES MISTER CHAIR --
AND THE WAY I THINK WE
ARTICULATED IS THAT THIS.
PROPOSAL -- IS ONE WHERE -- THE
WE THINK THE FISCAL INCENTIVES
ARE REALLY -- WORKING -- VERY
MUCH AT ODDS WITH THE INTENT OF
THE PROGRAM -- THE I THINK THE
GOAL OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
GRANT WAS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WERE IDENTIFIED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES WHO
NEED EXTRA SUPPORT.
BUT BY TYING THE FUNDING TO THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WRITE DOWN A
FIDE.
THE STATE WOULD EFFECTIVELY
PENALIZE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING
IDENTIFICATION RATES AND REWARD
THOSE TO KEEP IDENTIFICATION
RATES HIGH.
AND WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
SMALL POTATOES HERE THE ON THE
MARGIN THE AMOUNT FOR PER
STUDENT WOULD BE MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SO THAT IS
GOING TO WE THINK WE'LL HAVE A
PRETTY STRONG AFFECTING HOW
DISTRICTS THINK ABOUT SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND HOW MANY STUDENTS
TO IDENTIFY.
WE THINK YOU HAVE SOME BETTER
ALTERNATIVES STACK YOU COULD DO
IN PLACE OF THIS PROPOSAL. ONE
WOULD BE TO EQUALIZING SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING WE THINK THAT
COULD.
I PROVIDE DISTRIBUTE FUNDING
MORE BROADLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
HISTORICAL INEQUITIES THAT
YOU'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT IN
THE PAST.
WE ALSO THINK YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT HAVING A PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON AT A
PRESCHOOL.
SPECIAL EDUCATION CURRENTLY THE
STATE DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR THAT EVEN
THOUGH DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE IT.
I WE THINK A SMALLER MORE
TARGETED PROGRAM COULD ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IDENTIFIED AND
YOU MIGHT HAVE IN THAT AREA.
SO WITH THAT LET ME TURN THINGS
THINGS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR
A QUICK RUN.
ON THE PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE
SAID THE BUDGET BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT I MEAN.
MY CONCERN WITH THE SPECIAL ED.
PROPOSAL MAYBE PERHAPS I COULD
BECOME CONCERNED ABOUT THE MONEY
BEING DRIVEN TO ELEAZAR WITH
MORE THAN THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
SURE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
BUT YOU'RE LEAST DRIVING THE
MONEY DOWN. TWO STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS MY CONCERN IS THIS
55% OF THRESHOLD FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS.
FOSTER KIDS I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT HAS TO DO.
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SPECIAL NEEDS.
DO YOU.
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE ANOTHER
REASON WHY I WOULD SWITCH
SUGGEST WE RECOMMEND YOU REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL -- THEY'RE JUST
WAITING BETTER WAYS TO TARGET.
THE MONEY THIS DOESN'T REALLY WE
THINK GET AT KIND OF THE QUICK
CONCERNS THAT THE GOVERNOR WANTS
TO ADDRESS BECAUSE AS I'VE
IDENTIFIED IN A IN A PREVIOUS.
SESSION IN THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE I HAVE CONCERNS.
WHAT ABOUT THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT ITSELF AND HOW THAT
OPERATES WHEN YOU HAVE TO
SCHOOLS ON EITHER SIDE OF A
DISTRICT LINE? ONE IN THE
DISTRICT WITH 56%.
AND ONE OF THE DISTRICT OF 46%
BUT THE TWO ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
EACH HAVE 70% OF THE STUDENTS.
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND FOSTER
KIDS.
AND IT DOESN'T COST ANY LESS TO
EDUCATE THOSE STUDENTS IN THE
DISTRICT WITH 46%.
THAN IT DOES IN THE DISTRICT
WITH 56%.
AND NOW WE'RE LAYERING ANOTHER.
MUCH OF STUFF.
A TIED TO CONCENTRATION GRANTS
SO ANYWAY.
NOW WE CAN SHIFT OF ANOTHER
GIVEN MY AROUND YOU.
YES MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING THEIR CARD HAS LA --
I WAS ASKED TO GIVE A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE EARLY EDUCATION
BUDGET AS A CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL.
THE MAY REVISION INCREASES --
TELL CAN PRESCHOOL SPENDING BY
SEVENTY NINE MILLION COMPARED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THIS
IS A COMBINATION OF A DECREASE
IN GENERAL FUND AN INCREASE IN
FEDERAL FUNDS.
I'M A FEW MAIN A FEW MAIN THINGS
TO KNOW WITH THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL.
ON THE GOVERNOR IN JANUARY
PROPOSED TEN THOUSAND FLIGHTS TO
START JULY -- ONE AND SOME OF
THAT DECREASE IN GENERAL FUND IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE MOVING THAT
START DATE UNTIL APRIL ONE SO
DELAYED START SO DELAYED COSTS.
ON THIS THIS A SECOND THING WITH
REGARD TO STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
IS THE GOVERNOR'S WITHDRAWING
HIS THREE YEAR PLAN JUST TO
INCREASE TO PROVIDE THIRTY
THOUSAND SLOTS WITHIN THREE
YEARS AND ONLY PROVIDING THE
FIRST.
ONLY PLANS PROVIDE THE FIRST OF
THOSE.
THE FIRST OF THAT PLAN THE TEN
THOUSAND FLIGHTS -- WE DO NOT
HAVING A LONG TERM PLAN TO SERVE
LOW INCOME FOR REAL SO TO
PROVIDE THOSE THIRTY THOUSAND
FOUGHT TO RAISES SOME CONCERNS
FOR US WITH REMOVING THE WORK
REQUIREMENT.
A WE THINK REMOVING THE WORK
REQUIREMENT COULD RESULT IN
SERVING FEWER CHIN -- SERVING
FEWER CHILDREN -- AND SERVING
LESS WORKING FAMILIES -- JUST
THE WAY SOME OF THE SHIFTING
MIGHT HAPPEN THAT WITH SOME.
REPHRASE RE RE RAISING SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS WE'VE HAD IN
JANUARY NOT HAVING A PLAN TO
SERVE ALL LOW INCOME PEOPLE A
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD BY THE
STATE COULD EXACERBATE SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS.
THE THE THE IN THE MAY REVISION
THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSE SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THE ONE
TIME A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES WORKFORCE IN PLANNING
INITIATIVES.
THE TRICK SPECIFICALLY THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE
WORK OF THE FACILITY PROPOSAL.
A WE RAISE CONCERNS WITH -- THAT
THESE MAY REFER MAY REVISION
LANGUAGE CHANGES AND MINIMIZE
LEGISLATIVE IT IN PUT.
ON THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFIES THAT BY MARCH FIRST
ADMINISTRATION WILL -- WILL
DEVELOP A LOT OF THE TO THE KEY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS OF THIS
PROGRAM.
AND ALSO THAT THE GRANT PROGRAM
WILL CONSIDER RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE MASTER PLAN THAT WILL BE
DEVELOPED UNTIL OCTOBER --
TWENTY TWENTY SO AND MOVING ON
TO SOME OF THE FEDERAL FOR A THE
FEDERAL FUND COMPONENT OF THIS
THE MAIN REVISION.
WARS RECENT INCREASES TO FEDERAL
CC TO A FEDERAL GRAND AS ON
GOING.
AND THE GOVERNOR LAYS OUT A PLAN
FOR HOW TO SPEND THESE FEDERAL
FUNDS OF SOME FOR PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES AND SOME FOR A NEW
PROGRAM.
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THIS IS
ONE WAY TO SPEND THE FUNDS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE
DISCRETION ON ON HOW TO SPEND
THESE FUNDS WITH REGARD TO CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS IN ANY WAY IT.
IN ANY WAY IT COULD DECIDE -- SO
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
LEGISLATURE COULD DECIDE TO USE
FUNDS DIFFERENTLY -- AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS FROM HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIND
JACKSON.
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE
GIVEN A REALLY GOOD OVER VIEW OF
THE MAY REVISIONS ALL HIT ON
SOME HIGH POINTS OUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE.
OF THE FIRST REALLY WANT -- TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ELEVATING THE EDUCATIONAL ISSUES
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK THAT
WORK WITH THEM DURING THIS
TRANSITION PERIOD.
THE DEPARTMENT APPRECIATES THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUE COMMITMENT
TO K. TWELVE EDUCATION FUNDING.
PARTICULARLY IN IS ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER TRAINING STEAM AND EARLY
EDUCATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR STUDENTS
ADDITIONAL DIGITAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THE TO SUPERINTENDENT
APPRECIATES.
THE TO SEE THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MAY REVISION FOR
STATE COMPUTER SCIENCE
COORDINATOR AS WELL AS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
BROADBAND INTERNET CAPACITY. FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ADDITIONAL WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR DISH --
INVESTMENTS IN THE TEACHER
PIPELINE.
ALMOST NINETY MILLION TO PROVIDE
FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
TEACHERS UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GRANTS FOR TEACHING
IN CERTAIN SCHOOLS AND SUBJECT
AREAS.
ALMOST FORTY FIVE MILLION AND
ONE TIME NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT JOURNAL FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TRAINING A RESOURCES TO
CLASSROOM TEACHERS [inaudible]
EDUCATORS.
INCLUDING TEACHERS IMPAIR
PROFESSIONALS IN ORDER TO BUILD
CAPACITY AROUND INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES AND AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES.
AS WELL AS SUBJECT MATTER
COMPETENCE INCLUDING STEM.
ANOTHER ALMOST OF FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR FAST PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC.
K. TWELVE SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
TO PROVIDE KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND
COMPETENCIESNECESSARY TO
SUCCESSFULLY SUPPORT THE DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION SERVED IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONALLY AND IMPORTANTLY
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
INVESTMENTS IN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT THE ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION AND NON PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IS HUGE.
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP
DISTRICTS SCHOOLS IN COUNTY
OFFICES PREPARE FOR STUDENTS
PREPARE STUDENTS TO SUCCEED IN
THE FUTURE. FOR EXAMPLE THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSES THE ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION A ONE
TIME NON PROP NINETY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS AND CAL STIRS.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT AS IT WILL
PROVIDE PHYSICAL RELIEF TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR THE RISING
COSTS OF PENSIONS.
AND AS WE KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
AS SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THIS RESPECTFUL RETIREMENT OF
YOUR EMPLOYEES AND TEACHERS.
AS WELL AS MEETING THE FISCAL
THEIR FISCAL OPERATING
OBLIGATIONS.
THE SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORTS AND
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL -- ALL
A HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING PROPOSE
FUNDING -- FOR SPECIAL ED SO
THAT ELEAZAR CAN MEET THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES ON
THAT PROVISIONS OF THE IDA.
RECOGNIZING THAT THE STATE'S
HIGHEST NEEDS USE OFTEN REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORTS SERVICES
EMPLACEMENTS.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS CALLING ON THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
CONGRESS. TO FULLY MEET THEIR
FULL IDA I. D. E. A. OBLIGATIONS.
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT ITEM IS
AFFORDABLE TEACHER HOUSING WE
SEEN BODIES OF EVIDENCE AND WE
SEE OUR COMMUNITIES HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR TEACHERS TO
ACQUIRE -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE HOUSING.
AND WE KNOW WHEN WE INVEST IN
OUR TEACHERS THEY WILL THEN
INVEST IN OUR STUDENTS.
IT IS VITAL THAT ARE DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS -- BE ABLE.
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN OUR
BRIGHTEST TEACHERS.
THE GOVERNOR'S UP BUDGET
INCLUDED SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO PARTNER WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION THROUGH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN GENERAL
PURPOSE FUNDING.
OF WHICH JURISDICTIONS WILL
RECEIVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ON THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION.
FORCE A SIT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND STAFFING.
THE MAY REVISION AD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AS JURISDICTIONS
ELIGIBLE FOR PORTION OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
A DIFFERENT ADDITIONALLY THE MAY
REVISE ALSO PROPOSES TO EXPAND
TAX CREDITS UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY UP
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION OF THE
NEWLY AUTHORIZED CREDITS WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO INCREASE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF MIXING COME HOUSING PROJECTS
TO SERVE A BROADER RANGE OF
INCOMES UP TO A HUNDRED AND 20%
OF A MRI.
AND THIS WOULD ALLOW MORE
TEACHERS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WITH RESPECT EARLY EDUCATION THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY
REVISIONS PROPOSAL -- FOR A
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION IN
PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS FOR
SERVING SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND
THE GENERAL CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
AND IN CLOSING WERE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF RECOGIZED AND
SUPPORTED THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO EMPLOYMENT.
THE NEW AND EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND HAVE PROVIDED PROVISION
POSITIONS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS WILL BE.
PROPERLY IMPLEMENTED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IRON OUT THE
DETAILS OF THE MAY REVISION.
AND ONCE AGAIN APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S CONTINUED SUPPORT TO
EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
ANYTHING FURTHER ON CHILD CARE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
SAYING NOT WE WILL GO TO
CALIFORNIA MANY COLLEGES JUST
MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LARA MATTOON
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR
OAKLEY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNIST BEACH TODAY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE MAY REVISION.
WE WANTED TO JUST RAISE A FEW
AREAS OF I DID WHERE WE BELIEVE
ADDITIONAL WORK IS NECESSARY --
FIRST WE DON'T BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
MAKE CHANGES TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA IN THE CURRENT YEAR IS
FEASIBLE.
I'M DISTRICTS ARE JUST FORTY
SEVEN DAYS AWAY FROM ENDING
THEIR CURRENT BUDGET YEAR --
THERE AND WE THINK THAT ASKING
THEM TO MAKE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME IS IMPRACTICAL I WOULD LIKE
TO ASSURE ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE TO
DISTRICTS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SO THAT THEY RECEIVE THE
EXPECTED.
OF FUNDING AMOUNTS IN THAT YEAR.
I WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE EXISTING
PROVISIONS FOR THE COMMITTING
MINIMUM REVENUES FOR DISTRICTS
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
EXTENDING ESSENTIALLY THAT HOME
HOLD HARMLESS FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
YEAR -- AND WE ALSO AGREE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THE
FUNDING FORMULA DOES WARRANT
ADDITIONAL REVIEW.
WE BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT FOR
CHANGES TO BE MADE IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY A YEAR IT'S
CRITICAL THAT COLLEGES HAVE SOME
ADVANCE NOTICE OF THOSE CHANGES
AND THEREFORE WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THOSE CHANGES INCORPORATED INTO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET -- FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
THREE CHANGES THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY THAT
RESPOND TO SOME CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
OF FIRST WE'D LIKE TO CHANGE THE
FUNDING FORMULA SUCCESS METRICS
TO COUNT ONLY THE HIGHEST AWARD
ACHIEVED IN A SINGLE YEAR --
RATHER THAN EVERY DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE THAT THE CHIEF.
SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO COUNT
TRANSFERS IN THE DISTRICT OF
RESIDENTS ONLY IF THE STUDENT
HAS COMPLETED A MINIMUM MINIMUM
NUMBER OF UNITS AT THAT IN THAT
DISTRICT TWELVE UNITS IS THE
NUMBER WERE RECOMMENDING.
AND THEN THIRD AND C. T. E.
CERTIFICATE ATTAINMENT ALL RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN RECEIVE A BONUS FOR
ACHIEVING NINE C. T. E. UNITS
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE NINE UNITS ARE ALL IN THE
SAME DISCIPLINE NOT JUST A
RANDOM SHOT OF NINE UNITS.
WILL BE TRANSMITTING A LETTER TO
YOU IN THE COMING DAYS -- THAT
SUPPORTS THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
I'M IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL AID
WE'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
THAT TUITION IS NOT A BARRIER TO
OUR STUDENTS -- WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR A SECOND
YEAR OF COLLEGE PROMISE WELL
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE
FREE TUITION COMPONENT OF
COLLEGE PROMISE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THE COLLEGE
PROMISES REALLY A STRATEGY. FOR
ENSURING STUDENTS KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A PATHWAY TO WIN THROUGH
OUR COLLEGES COLLEGES ARE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE
BASED STRATEGIES THAT SUPPORT
STUDENT SUCCESS AND TO MAXIMIZE
ACCESS TO EXISTING NEED BASED
AID SUCH AS PELL GRANT AND CAL
GRANT FOR THOSE STUDENTS THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE.
BUT WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT FAR TOO
FEW STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT WHICH IS
WHY WE CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
SENATE BILL -- TWO NINETY ONE
WHICH WOULD CREATE A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM FOCUSED EXPLICITLY ON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR FOOD
AND HOUSING COSTS.
AND ARE SPECIFIC REQUESTS THERE
IS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET TO BEGIN THAT
PROGRAM I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
IN REGARDS TO THE RAPID RE
HOUSING ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
EARLIER -- THAT FUNDING APPEARS
TO COME FROM US SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THAT'S A BILL THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF AND WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OFF IN NON
NINETY EIGHT RESOURCES THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO OUR
SYSTEM. TO IMPLEMENT RAPID RE
HOUSING ACROSS THE SYSTEM -- I
FINALLY JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S -- RECOGNITION
OF THE STAFFING NEEDS IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
APPROPRIATION OF ADDITIONAL
THREE POSITIONS TO HELP US FOR
FILL CORE FUNCTIONS.
RELATED TO FISCAL MONITORING AND
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE APPRECIATED THE
CONVERSATION THAT OCCURRED LAST
WEEK REGARDING THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTEREST IN UNDERSTANDING HOW
CURRENT -- POSITION ALLOCATIONS
ARE BEING USED IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND WE'RE
ADDITIONAL NEEDS MIGHT EXIST SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT.
I ONCE AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND THE FOCUS AT THIS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PLACES ON THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE THE COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM.
THAT ALSO WITH THAT ALSO APPLIES
AND MAYBE WE COVERED THIS BEFORE
AND I'VE JUST FORGOTTEN THAT
ALSO APPLIES TO A STUDENT WHO
DOESN'T IMMEDIATELY MOVE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUT IN ROLES MAYBE AT THE THREE
YEAR POINT.
SO THE WAY THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT WORKS.
ANY STUDENT CAN RECEIVE A FEE
WAIVER IF THEY HAVE FINANCIAL
NEED.
IF A STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED.
THEY CAN FALL INTO THIS COLLEGE
PROMISE FRAMEWORK AND THAT DOES
APPLY TO STUDENTS THAT GO
STRAIGHT FROM HIGH SCHOOLINTO
COLLEGE SHE DOES NOT HAVE NEED
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE BUT IF A
STUDENT HAS NEED.
THEY WOULD RECEIVE A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT.
WHICH WAS FORMERLY CALLED THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS FEE WAIVER
WHICH MIGHT BE THE WAY THAT YOU
KNOW.
I'M JUST TRYING TO YOU KNOW OF
I'M I'VE BEEN BOTHERED SINCE I
ASSUME THIS TOOK THIS ASSIGNMENT.
BY THE FACT THAT THE IF YOU.
TAKE CARE OF YEAR AND A HALF OR
TWO TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING
ON AFTER YOU GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
YOU FALL INTO THIS AND YOU HAVE
NEED YOU FALL INTO THIS
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS WE'RE
APPARENTLY ONLY 10% OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEED RECEIVE THE
RECEIVE HELP.
AND I WAS JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS.
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM IN --
INTERACTED WITH THAT BY THAT
LOCATION YEAH THAT'S STUDENTS
THAT COMES TO US FIVE OR TEN
YEARS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL THAT HAS
FINANCIAL NEED WOULD STILL
QUALIFY TO RECEIVE A TUITION
WAIVER -- UNDER THE PROMISE
GRANT.
AND WE WOULD TRYING PACKAGE
THEIR AID SO THAT WE COULD
ACCESS EITHER A COMPETITIVE
GRANT OR A PELL GRANT -- OTHER
RESOURCES THAT COULD HELP OFFSET
THEIR NON TUITION COST.
THANK YOU DO NEED LABOR. FOR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT.
THIS.
FINISHES THE ISSUE.
PRESENTATION.
NOW PUBLIC COMMENT.
LIZ BUT THAT'S ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ONE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR LOW -- LCF
OFTEN THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT.
I DO WANT TO MENTION AND THE MAY
REVISION ADMINISTRATION IS
SHIFTING THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE P. S. S. A.
ACCOUNT THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILITY ACCOUNT. FOR THE
201-920-2019 TWENTY FISCAL YEAR
THESE DOLLARS WILL COUNT TOWARDS
MEDIAN THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL MINIMUM GUARANTEE BUT
WILL NOT BE ACCESSIBLE DOLLARS
FOR TODAY STUDENTS AND THEIR
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS.
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
SUMMER SYSTEMS PROGRAM.
ARE WE OPPOSE A REDIRECTION OF
RESOURCES FOR TO PROGRAM THAT IS
NOT TIED TO EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
NOR IMPROVING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE LOW.
LOS WAGE EMPLOYEES WE DO SUPPORT
THE INCREASE AND ONGOING FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTION MODEL IN A B. FOR
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA.
WE SUPPORT THE NATIONAL HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AS A
DOWN PAYMENT FOR CAL STORES
EMPLOYER RATE FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO INVEST IN
UPGRADES TO BROADBAND SERVICES
AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND
WILDFIRE RELATED COST.
WE SUPPORT THE EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
EARLY EDUCATION AS WELL AS THE
FOR CHARTER SCHOOL POLICIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE AND KATHY
VAN AUSTIN REPRESENTING JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE UC AND CSU RAPID RE HOUSING
FUNDING.
AND WE JUST FEEL VERY STRONGLY
WITH THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
THE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH VETERANS
THOSE WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THOSE WHO'VE NEVER ESTABLISHED
CREDIT HISTORY -- ARE OFTEN
VULNERABLE AND BY IN THAT HAVE
GREAT DIFFICULTY FINDING HOUSING
SO THE RAPID RE HOUSING MODELS
REALLY.
LONG TERM MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE
APPROACH.
I WHAT I WOULD POINT -- TO AS
LORD MATTOON HAD INDICATED SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR
PORTANTINO'S LEGISLATION WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE.
REVENUES FOR RAPID RE HOUSING AT
CSU YOU SEE AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
OF WERE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LEFT OUT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BYTES AND
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL -- THAT HAS
WORKED ON AND LOS ANGELES FOR
RAPID RE HOUSING SO WE WOULD
URGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
LANGUAGE SENATOR ROTH YOU'RE A
CO AUTHOR ON THAT LANGUAGE AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW -- BUT WE WOULD
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EVEN IF IT'S GENERAL FUND
FUNDING.
FOR A SEAT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ONE IN FIVE OF THEIR
STUDENTS REPORT THAT THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS THE
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR.
SO THEY HAVE A HUGE POPULATION
THAT NEEDS ATTENTION ON THIS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CENTER
MORALE JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
ARE JUST SOME BRIEF COMMENTS ON
A SMALL NUMBER OF ISSUES TODAY.
I WITH REGARD TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN FUNDING
AND WE SUPPORT -- THE SWITCH
OVER TO ALL OF THE FUNDING BEING
ONGOING.
A CENTER ROTH WE SHARE.
THE CONCERNS THAT YOU.
OUTLINED REGARDING THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDS WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT.
ALLOCATION METHOD.
IS THE WAY TO GO AND WE WOULD
ALSO AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
FOR MR COUPON.
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THAT ARE BOTH
EQUALIZATION.
AND A DIRECTION OF FUNDS TOWARD.
A STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES IN
EARLY EDUCATION WOULD BE A FAR
MORE BENEFICIAL TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND THEN WITH REGARD TO THE
PROPOSALS FOR EDUCATORS SUPPORT --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE AND
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZING.
OF THE ON GOING TEACHER SHORTAGE
CRISIS.
WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH COMMENTS
ON EARLY EDUCATION AND OTHER
ISSUES.
IN THE DAYS TO COME THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
THANK YOU A CHAIR SENATOR
MEMBERS A STAFF OF BY BLATTER ON
BEHALF OF FRESNO UNIFIED -- I
SHARE MR BACCHUS CONCERNS WE DO
ABOUT OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM ONE SPECIFICITY ABOUT
FRESNO AS YOU MAY KNOW WHAT THE
FOURTH LARGEST DISTRICT IN THE
STATE.
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WE HAVE
THE SECOND HIGHEST CONCENTRATION
OF INTENSE POVERTY.
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO SEVENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR -- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROGRAM WOULD SEND US
EXACTLY ZERO DOLLARS.
BECAUSE WE ARE BELOW THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE -- WE FEAR
THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING TO ADVANCE THE LC OF
PFAFF AS FAR AS EQUITY
RATIONALITY OR TRANSPARENCY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
YES MA'AM EMILY ROSENBERGER WAS
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IS A NUMBER OF ITEMS IN
THE BUDGET THAT WAS FOR I'LL
ALSO BE SENDING A LETTER BUT I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT THE SUMMER --
CLASSIFIED -- EMPLOYEES SUMMER
BRIDGE ASSISTANCE THE NUMBER OF
NAMES ABOUT IT BUT WE HELP GET
THAT IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR'S
AND WE WORKED ON FOR SIX YEARS.
ARE CLASSIFIED WORKERS RECEIVE
NOTHING DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS --
I MEMBERS.
PARTICIPATE IN IT THEY USE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO JOIN IN
ON THE SUMMER BRIDGE THAT GIVE
US ONE YEAR WITHOUT A QUARTER OF
THE MONEY WE NEEDED.
THIS UGH THE GOVERNOR'S MY
REVISION ALLOWS IT TO CONTINUE
FOR ONE MORE YEAR SO I MEMBERS
AREN'T LEFT IN THE LURCH AND
RELYING ON FOOD BANKS OR I'M
JUST GOING HUNGRY SO WE WOULD
REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT IN
CONTINUING THAT PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ROB
SENATOR MORALE AND JAKE RENDER
ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY THERE'S MUCH
THAT WE APPRECIATE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISED BUDGET
PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY AROUND
INVESTMENTS.
TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY TO
SERVE MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
THAT THE CSU -- AND INVESTMENTS
AND FINANCIAL AID IN
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEMS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR
STUDENTS THERE ARE STILL AREAS
WHERE WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR -- PARTICULARLY AROUND --
TO YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR ROTH
I'M INSURING THAT INVESTMENTS IN
OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM REALLY
ADDRESSED THE HUNDREDS.
OF THOUSANDS OF DENIED ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WERE APPLYING FOR THAT
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
AND WE DO MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HELPING THE STUDENTS
ADDRESS THEIR NON TUITION
EXPENSES.
I'M WE ALSO HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN WORK WITH.
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
THAT ANY LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM THAT WE ESTABLISH IN THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WILL. FOR
IT -- INCLUDES EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS IN ADDITION TO OUR
INSTITUTIONAL PARTNERS AND
REALLY HAS SOME TO CLEAR GOALS
AROUND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
STATUS SYSTEM AND HOW THE
STATE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THAT TO IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS.
AND CLOSE THE A DEGREES GAP THAT
WE STILL FACE AND FINALLY WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR TO
IDENTIFY THE ABILITY TO SERVE
MORE OF OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SHORT BY OVER
ONE MILLION BACHELOR'S DEGREES
BY TWENTY THIRTY TO MEET
WORKFORCE NEEDS AND NEED TO
EXPAND THE ABILITY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO SERVE MORE
STUDENTS AS WERE INCREASING.
A THREE G. COMPLETION RATES ARE
HIGH SCHOOLS AND FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF OUR CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INVESTMENTS IN LEGAL
SERVICES FUNDING -- BOTH AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SOURCE.
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES CENTER
WITH THE SLIGHT INCREASE IN THE
MAY REVISIONS STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND WE SUPPORT THAT
PROPOSAL I THANK YOU THANKS SIR
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING TO
SPEECH ON THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROPOSAL FOR
FACILITIES WE'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE DO ASK YOU TO PLEASE FIX
THE ELIGIBILITY ISSUES SO THERE
IS A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FUNDS
THAT YOU WOULD RECEIVE IN THIS
PROGRAM.
AND OUR TYPICAL SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM WHERE SCHOOLS RECEIVE
FUNDS FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION -- RIGHT NOW A NEW
CLASSROOM THAT YOU WOULD BUILD
THROUGH THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM WOULD END UP
BEING CHARGED AGAINST YOUR BASS
LINE ELIGIBILITY IN THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM.
SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT WOULD
BE A HIT AGAINST FUTURE PROJECTS
THAT A DISTRICT MAY NEED TO DO
IN THE K. THROUGH SIXTH GRADE
CATEGORY.
SO NOT JUST KINDERGARTEN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN FIX WE
URGE YOU TO DO SO.
BUT WE ALSO DON'T SEE A NEED TO
ADJUST THE MATCH FROM 5275% THIS
IS BECAUSE MOST OF THE DOLLARS
IN THE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN ARE
BEING TARGETED TO LOW INCOME --
DISTRICTS THOSE ARE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP PROGRAM WHERE
THEY SEE A LARGER MATCH FROM THE
STATE.
SO THERE'S NO REASON TO ADJUST
FROM 5275% BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALREADY RECEIVING MORE -- AND
THEN ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACILITY COALITION I
JUST WANTED TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING THE THIRTY
NINE POINT SIX MILLION.
AND OF COURSE THERE'S A NEXUS
BETWEEN -- MAINTENANCE AND
CAPITAL OUTLAYS SO WE URGE YOU
TO FUND ALL THIRTY NINE OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE APPROVED BY
THE BOARD OF OVERNORS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT.
WHO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IAN
PEDIA RIGHT -- REPRESENTING
TODAY -- COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIA SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION MANAGERS AND THIS
IS ON PROPOSITION FOR A FIFTY
ONE BONDS -- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION -- BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE IS AN ALLEY FOR
NEARLY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROJECTS RIGHT NOW THAT IF
THEY'RE NOT FUNDED -- IN A MORE
ACCELERATED MANNER -- IF YOU
IT'LL BE A QUITE A FEW YEARS
BEFORE THOSE -- THE KIDS
BASICALLY ARE ABLE -- TO UTILIZE
THOSE FACILITIES SO WE SUPPORT.
INCREASED OF MORE THAN THAT
AMOUNT AND CERTAINLY SENATOR --
MAGUIRE'S PROPOSAL -- TO TO FUND
THE WHOLE -- ABOVE -- LIST AS
WELL AS THE STAFF RESOURCES
NECESSARY -- TO PROCESS THE
APPLICATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCANDREW
IT ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION I LIKE MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME WERE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ADDITIONAL
ONGOING FUNDING -- UNDER THE
UMBRELLA OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
BUT WE REMAIN CONCERNED AS YOU
DO AND THE LA -- DOES AND MANY
OTHERS ABOUT THE FUNDING
METHODOLOGY THAT'S PROPOSED FOR
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT YOU MAY
REMEMBER THE THE DATA POINT THAT
ONLY ABOUT A QUARTER OF ELEAZAR
WOULD RECEIVE THESE FUNDS.
THOSE THAT QUALIFY BOTH WITH A
CONCENTRATION GRANT AND THE
ABOVE AVERAGE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES --
ONE DATA POINT THAT I RECENTLY
ACQUIRED AS THAT OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION POPULATION THERE'S
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND ONLY ABOUT 6% WOULD
ACTUALLY GENERATE THESE FUNDS SO
THE OTHER AT 9294% OF STUDENTS
WHEN GENERATED FUNDS.
WE KNOW THAT THE NEED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING AS
STATEWIDE -- WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE -- DIS EQUALIZATION'S AROUND
THE STATE AND WE THINK INSTEAD
OF DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT AND
ALREADY RECEIVE -- MORE UNDER AB
SIX OR TO RECEIVE IT EVEN MORE
THROUGH THIS CONCENTRATION GRANT
WE THINK THAT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING IS EQUALIZING -- AB SIX OH
TWO PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND FOR THOSE
WITH HIGH COSTS NEEDS -- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
PROPOSING UNDER EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU WOULD CONSIDER ABOUT FOR THE
SIX HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
BEING PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTER MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
UP PUSH ON THE UC STERN
ASSOCIATION -- WE WERE VERY
HAPPY AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE THAT
MAINLY WAS BUDGET THAT INCLUDED
ESPECIALLY THE HOT THROUGHOUT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR RAPIDLY
HOUSING.
SO WE'D LIKE TO DECLARE SUPPORT
FOR THAT AS WELL AS THE
INCREASED OUR LEGAL SERVICES
FUNDING.
FOR REGRESSIONASSUMES THAT THE
UC -- COUPLE THINGS THAT WERE
NOT INVOLVED INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REALIZE WHERE ARE WE NEED AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON TOP OF WHAT'S
ALREADY PROPOSED -- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT AND WE ALSO
NEED -- DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
OTHER COLLEGE IN THIS BLOCK
GRANT FUNDING THAT WE HAD BEEN
SEEKING.
HARM AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
A HUGE PRIORITY TO US.
AND FINALLY THERE'S ALSO NO
FUNDING THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO
THE UNIVERSITY ON TOP OF WHAT
WAS ALREADY THERE -- TO WHAT
JUST FOR HE ENROLLMENT EXPANSION
AND AND THE NEED FOR FUNDING TO
MAINTAIN THE TUITION FROZEN
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT YEAR AND WE
KNOW THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS.
COMMITTED THAT THE STATE --
RESIDENT TUITION DOESN'T
INCREASE NEXT YEAR BUT IF THE
FUNDING DOESN'T COME TO
UNIVERSITY.
NEXT YEAR VERY SOON WE WILL BE
EXPECTING ANOTHER TUITION
INCREASE TO WOULD LIKE THESE
FINDINGS TO BE INCLUDED THANK
YOU THANKS FOR NEXT THIS BILL.
HI MICHELLE SO APARTMENT SKI
FROM CANANGA WHICH IS AN EARLY
LEARNING NONPROFIT AND WE'RE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY
REVISE INVESTMENTS IN EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION WHICH BUILD OFF OF
THOSE GOVERNORS AND PROPOSE
INVESTMENTS IN JANUARY -- WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THERE STILL
REMAINS A GAP IN TERMS OF INFANT
AND TODDLER HIGH QUALITY CHILD
CARE SPACES -- BUT WE KNOW THAT
THAT THERE'S A REALLY CRITICAL
NEED THEIR Là ABOUT ONE IN --
TEN ELIGIBLE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS IS ACTUALLY BEING
SERVED WITH WITH CHILD CARE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE I'M IT WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN TO BE
PREPARED FOR PRESCHOOL AND
ULTIMATELY FOR KINDERGARTEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM X. IS
MAKE YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA
BALL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
CHOLISH AND ON THE SPECIAL ED
FUNDING WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
THAT'S OUR THERE'S IN THE
INCREASING FUNDING AND SHIFTING
IT TO ON GOING BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AS
CHAIR ROTH AND YOU HEARD EARLIER
FOR MISTER BLATTER ABOUT FRESNO
UNIFIED A LARGE DISTRICT WILL IN
OUR CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION IS PRIMARILY SMALL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
I THINK THEY WOULD BE IN THE
SAME POSITION WHERE THEY HAVE
POVERTY BUT THEY ARE NOT PERHAPS
AT THE 55% OR ABOVE AND THEY
WOULD NOT RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS.
THEY ARE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS.
ON THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATOR ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS BEST
FOR YOU ON THE STATE OUR SUPPORT.
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT --
PROPOSAL AND THE FACT THAT IT
WILL ADDRESS SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AS
WELL AS SUBJECT MATTER AREAS
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
HONORABLE TERRON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS AMY HEINZ LIKE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES -- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ADDRESSING OUR ISSUES
ARE WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
WILL UNLESS SOMETHING CHANGES BE
GOING ON STRIKE ON THURSDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH THERE'S FIFTEEN
THOUSAND OF US AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AFGHANI LOCAL THIRTY TO
NINETY NINE EMPLOYEES ARE
SCHEDULED TO ALSO BE STRIKING --
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR THIS MAY REVISED TO THE
STATE BUDGET PROPOSAL STATES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE UC RETIREMENT PROGRAM.
HOWEVER OUR BUDGET REQUEST IS
THIS STATE WOULD PROVIDE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION AND
PROPOSITION TWO OR GENERAL FUND
MONEY BUT PREFERABLY PROPOSITION
TWO MONEY TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE SPEND DOWN THERE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY AND AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING THE STATE FUNDS THE UC
WOULD AGREE TO WITHDRAW THEIR
BARGAINING DEMAND THAT THE
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES OF UP THE
CW A LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO NINETY
NINE BE FORCED TO ALLOW THE
DEFINED CONTRIBUTION.
PLAN OPTION FOR THEIR NEW
MEMBERS AT THIS CONDITIONALITY
IS EXTREMELY CRITICAL FOR THE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES THE
ASSOCIATION DEPENDING CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES JUST
TWO BRIEF COMMENTS -- FIRST IN
THE MAY REVISED ADMINISTRATION --
HAD ADJUSTMENT TO THE PROJECTED
COST TO IMPLEMENT SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT FOR CAL GRANT STUDENT
PARENT RECIPIENTS HOWEVER AT
THIS TIME IT STILL DOES NOT
PROVIDE -- THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS I
WOULD OTHERS ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED OF THESE CURRENT STUDENT
PARENTS -- THEIR CALORIE
RECIPIENTS IN OUR SECTOR
INCLUDING OVER THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I AND IF THAT IS TO MOVE FORWARD
WE WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO SEE
THOSE STUDENTS WERE TREATED
EQUITABLY BECAUSE THEY WE KNOW
THEIR NEEDS ARE SIMILAR
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
INSTITUTION THEY ATTEND -- AND
SECONDLY ON THE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM -- WE ARE VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF OF THAT AND WHAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE -- GIVEN
THAT WE PRODUCE ABOUT A FIFTH OF
THE UNDERGRADUATES AND THE
MAJORITY OF THE GRADUATE DEGREES
IN THE STATE -- THEY WERE ALSO
IN EDUCATION CODE AND WORK WITH
OUR COUNTERPARTS AT THE OTHER
SEGMENTS DO NAY COMMISSION
MISSION -- TO CREDENTIALING
CETERA IS WE WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO BE INCLUDED ON THAT WORK
GROUP TO HELP WRESTLE WITH THE
TYPES OF CONVERSATIONS AND
DECISIONS THAT WILL BE MADE
ABOUT HOW THAT'S GONNA LOOK
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE OCCUR
GONNA ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION COALITION WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION YET ON THE
ME REVISED PROPOSALS FOR EARLY
EDUCATION AND CHILDCARE.
WE ARE STILL ANALYZING AND
ATTEMPTING TO RECONCILE WHAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED AND WHAT IS IN
PRINT AND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
WILL FOLLOW SHORTLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE ONCE WE'VE CONDUCTED
THIS ANALYSIS AND TAKING
POSITION ON THE PROPOSALS THANK
YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LUIS I'M A
TWO THINGS ARM REPRESENTING
SCENIC THE CORPORATION FOR
EDUCATION NETWORK INITIALS IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTIVE OF THE I'M
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ADD
FIFTEEN MILLION MORE IN
BROADBAND GRANTS FOR SCHOOLS.
I'M AND THEN SWITCHING HATS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH WE WERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT GIPSON.
I'M WHICH EXPANDED PRIORITY FOR
ON CAMPUS HOUSING TO CURRENT AND
FORMER HOMELESS.
YOUTH I AM ON CAMPUS AS WELL AS
REQUESTING CAMPUSES TO HAVE
PLANS FOR HOW THEY'RE GONNA
DRESS STUDENTS DURING --
ACADEMIC AND DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR SO BE CURIOUS WHERE THEY'RE
AT IN TERMS OF HOW THIS FITS IN
WITH THAT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
AROUND THE RAPPER HOUSING THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR OF MICHAEL SIZER ON
BEHALF OF THE FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TURN KERN COUNTY I'M
GOING TO SPEAK FROM THE SAME
PERSPECTIVE THAT YOU HAVE MISTER
CHAIR.
AND OTHERS HERE ABOUT THE
CONCERNS OF INEQUITY IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
I'LL SAY SOME THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN SET THOUGH.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE ALL
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
BEEN ENTITLED TO THE SAME
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY STUDENTS IN
RIVERSIDE AND SALMON A DINO AND
BAKERSFIELD IN SACRAMENTO ARE
RIGHT NOW FUNDED ABOUT 30% LESS
THAN THE HIGHEST FUNDED
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE -- IN YET
THEY HAVE THE SAME OBLIGATION.
WE THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
PUTTING IN THE MONEY THAT HE'S
PUT IN -- IF THOSE DOLLARS WERE
EARMARKED TOWARDS EQUALIZATION
WE WOULD EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATE
THAT GAP.
BETWEEN THOSE LOW FUNDED
DISTRICTS AND SELF AS AN OUR
HIGHEST FUNDED IT DOESN'T SOLVE
THE ADEQUACY PROBLEM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT LIVING UP TO
ITS RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT THE EQUITY IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE GUARANTEE ALL
STUDENTS THE SAME LEVEL OF
SERVICES.
AND SO -- BASED UPON THE NEW
SPENDING AND REVENUE ESTIMATES
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
THINK THIS MAY BE THE LAST YEAR.
YOU'LL HAVE THESE KINDS OF
DOLLARS THESE DISCRETIONARY
DOLLARS TO YOUR MARK TOWARDS
THIS KIND OF INEQUITY.
AND BEFORE WE START BUILDING NEW
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ALL OF
THEM LAUDABLE AN ADMIRABLE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE ACT WITH THE
INEQUITY IN THE EXISTING SYSTEM
I'M SURE YOU'RE HEARING THAT
FROM YOUR DISTRICTS WE'RE
CERTAINLY HEARING IT.
IT'S THE HIGHEST PRIORITY OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS MIGHT
THE GROW REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS --
EXTREMELY LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
WE ARE CURRENTLY ANALYZING THE
EARLY CHILD CARE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL SO WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU ALL FOR
ATTENDING THE HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED